I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论暑假的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢住Airbnb。我知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房，我喜欢早上能穿着睡袍走出来喝杯茶，正如你所说的，Jenna，我喜欢长长的跑道。是的。嗯，你知道，Lee现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去看他，他给我们全家找了一个非常好的Airbnb住。这样我们就可以分散开来，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会感觉就像在家里一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know, I don't know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right.
即使你在一个不同的城市。天哪，我不想和我的全家人睡在同一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了酒店了。是的，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。是的，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，一个真正的冰箱。我喜欢吃零食，如你所知，我不知道这个。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我想要它们就在那儿。没错。
Yeah. Everyone were ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. Welcome to our second drink of Valentine's episode. In this episode we had Andy Buckley as our guest, David Wallace. Yes, I remember he showed up in a yellow suck-it sweatshirt. Yes. And he brought us each a little Dunder Mifflin coffee mug. It was so sweet. So sweet. Well, I cannot tell you the amount of mail we got saying how much people loved this interview. Alison T said, I grew up in Lynn. So hearing Andy Buckley shout out the North Shore
是的。大家都是爱住Airbnb的女士，我想，对于你的下一次冒险，你的下一次假期，也许可以考虑Airbnb。欢迎来到我们情人节剧集的第二杯。在这一集中，我们请到了Andy Buckley作为嘉宾，David Wallace。是的，我记得他穿着一件黄色的“Suck-it”运动衫出现了。是的。他还给我们每人带了一个小小的Dunder Mifflin咖啡杯。太贴心了。太贴心了。嗯，我无法告诉你我们收到了多少邮件，说人们有多喜欢这次采访。Alison T说，我在Lynn长大。所以听到Andy Buckley提到North Shore
was the best. Ms. Bonita said, I have the biggest crush on Andy Buckley. And Megan M said, Andy Buckley was so great for this role. David Wallace was probably my favorite non-main cast member. Well, we also had a few folks write in to tell us a crazy fun fact about Andy and Lady. I did not know this. I so wish we would have asked him about it, but he was in two country music videos.
真是太棒了。Ms. Bonita说，我超级迷恋Andy Buckley。Megan M说，Andy Buckley在这个角色上表现得太棒了。David Wallace可能是我最喜欢的非主要演员。嗯，我们还有几个人写信告诉我们关于Andy的一个疯狂有趣的事实，Lady。我不知道这个。我真希望我们问过他，但他出演过两部乡村音乐录影带。
He was? Yes, both for Reba McIntyre. What? I went and watched them. No. Yes, so in 1997 he was in the music videos, I'd Rather Ride Around With You and What If It's You by Reba. And oh my goodness, in I'd Rather Ride Around With You, Andy is Reba's love interest. No. Yes, and they go on a road trip. It is so wild. And then in the song, What If It's You, he plays the guy who got away.
他演过？是的，都是Reba McIntyre的。什么？我去看过了。不。是的，1997年他出演了Reba的音乐录影带《I'd Rather Ride Around With You》和《What If It's You》。天哪，在《I'd Rather Ride Around With You》中，Andy是Reba的爱慕对象。不。是的，他们去公路旅行了。太疯狂了。然后在《What If It's You》这首歌里，他扮演那个逃跑的男人。
She like watches him longingly as he rides a horse on the beach. Then he canoodles with this other woman. I just need to ask him about this. We have to call him right now. Call him right now. Okay. I can't let another moment of my life go by. I know and like clearly she liked him. She put him in. Okay, I'm calling him. All right, Andy. Here
她看着他，渴望着他骑马在海滩上。然后他和另一个女人调情。我一定要问问他这件事。我们现在就得给他打电话。现在就打。好的。我不能让生命中的又一刻溜走。我知道，而且很明显她喜欢他。她让他参演了。好的，我给他打电话。好的，Andy。开始了。
goes. Let's see if he answers. Angela. Oh, Angela. Andy, it's me and Jenna. We're calling you from our podcast. Hello, young ladies. Hello, Jenna. Hi and Jenna. We're calling you from our podcast. Hello, young ladies. Hello, Jenna. Hi, Andy. We are revisiting the episode that you joined us on the podcast for Valentine's Day. And Andy, people wrote in and said they could not believe
看看他接不接。Angela。哦，Angela。Andy，是我和Jenna。我们正在从我们的播客给你打电话。你好，年轻的女士们。你好，Jenna。嗨，Andy。我们正在重温你参加我们情人节播客的那一集。Andy，人们写信说他们简直不敢相信
we did not ask you about being in Reba McEntire's music videos. Well, I don't go a day in my life without walking down the street without someone asking me about those. But you play her love interest in one. You guys go on a road trip. How did that come about? By the way, she is the greatest. She couldn't be nicer. She couldn't be lovelier. She is the queen of country music. But just as a human being, she's just, she's, you know, much like you two young ladies, just as kind and lovely as a person can be.
我们没有问你关于出演Reba McEntire音乐录影带的事。嗯，我每天走在街上，没有一天不被人问起那些事。但你在其中一个里扮演她的爱慕对象。你们去公路旅行了。那是怎么发生的？顺便说一句，她是最好的。她再好不过了。她再可爱不过了。她是乡村音乐的女王。但作为一个人类，她只是，你知道，就像你们两位年轻女士一样，是一个人所能有的最善良、最可爱的人。
And it's funny, I just think this is great. So I did two music videos with her in the course of like three weeks. So each one took like four days. So I was around her for like about eight days. Every single day, people come up to you and people come up to her, oh, you're great, you're great. But every day, there was always somebody
很有趣，我觉得这太棒了。所以我在三周的时间里和她拍了两部音乐录影带。每部大概拍了四天。所以我大概和她在一起待了八天。每一天，人们都会走近你，人们也会走近她，哦，你太棒了，你太棒了。但每一天，总会有人
who came up who was very emotional about her music and got them through some horrible period in their life. And she was the greatest. She would give each person as much time as they needed. I thought that was great. How did it come about? I had an agent at the time who was friends with someone who was producing the music video.
走过来，对她的音乐非常激动，说这些音乐帮助他们度过了生命中一段可怕的时期。她是最棒的。她会给每个人他们所需要的尽可能多的时间。我觉得那太棒了。那是怎么发生的？当时我有一个经纪人，他认识一个制作音乐录影带的人。
Originally, I was supposed to be a big actor that was gonna do it, but that person wanted to direct it. Like, yeah, I'll do it, I'll be the love interest, but I really wanna direct it, and push came to shove, and they're like, eh, we want the person who directed us to do it. So that fell out and then it was like four days before and they're like,
最初，本来应该是一个大牌演员来演的，但那个人想导演它。就像，是的，我会演，我会做爱慕对象，但我真的很想导演它，当压力来临时，他们说，呃，我们想要导演我们的人来做。所以那个人退出了，然后离拍摄还有四天，他们说，
hey, we got to find somebody in my agency. Hey, what about this guy Buckley? How'd you end up in the second music video? Here's my question. The first one, you're clearly her love interest. Then in the second one, you're like the guy that got away. You're riding a horse on the beach you're with some other gal now I had to break Reba's heart I would what if it's you yeah that was the other
嘿，我们得在我的经纪公司找个人。嘿，这个叫Buckley的家伙怎么样？你是怎么最终出现在第二个音乐录影带里的？这是我的问题。第一个里，你显然是她的爱慕对象。然后在第二个里，你就像那个逃跑的男人。你在海滩上骑马，你现在和另一个女孩在一起。我不得不伤Reba的心。我会的，如果是你，是的，那是另一回事。
thing yes so exciting I would go and I would sit there and I would listen to her sing you know it's music videos they sing along and they're playing the track but she's singing and it's I mean oh that was a treat and that's such a pretty song the other one's such a fun song. You got like a private Reba McIntyre concert. I did. Yeah. Wow. I guess this is this is going to be on the podcast. So you're on it right now.
是的，太令人兴奋了。我会去，我会坐在那里，我会听她唱歌，你知道，这是音乐录影带，他们跟着唱，他们播放音轨，但她在唱歌，我的意思是，哦，那真是一种享受，那是一首如此动听的歌，另一首是一首如此有趣的歌。你就像得到了一场私人的Reba McIntyre演唱会。是的。哇。我想这会出现在播客上。所以你现在就在播客上了。
It's OK. Sorry. Thank you for answering your phone. Yeah, exactly. It was in a place called Jekyll Island, which is North Florida's beautiful Savannah-like looking place, as I guess you can tell from looking at them. Yeah, I was very curious.
没关系。抱歉。谢谢你接电话。是的，没错。那是在一个叫Jekyll Island的地方，那是北佛罗里达一个美丽的像萨凡纳一样的地方，我想你可以从看它们中看出来。是的，我很好奇。
I thought it was the Caribbean or somewhere, and it looked like, wow, what a great gig. I mean, it was great. It was like I was doing much acting, and at the time I had done a few episodes of this show called Pacific Blue, which was instead of like a Baywatch thing it was Cops on Bikes, you know, but you know the main guy and then the cute girl Cops on Bikes by the beach.
我以为是加勒比海或其他什么地方，看起来，哇，多棒的工作啊。我的意思是，这很棒。就像我做了很多表演，当时我拍了几集叫《Pacific Blue》的剧，那不是像《海滩救护队》那样的东西，而是骑自行车的警察，你知道，但你知道主角和一个可爱的女孩骑着自行车在海滩上。
Sells itself. It sells itself. Yeah. That was about all, I did like two episodes of that. Well thank you so much for answering the phone because fans wanted to know about it. And so there you have it. And Andy, you're just a delight.
这本身就是卖点。这本身就是卖点。是的。差不多就是这样，我拍了两集。非常感谢你接电话，因为粉丝们想知道这件事。所以就是这样。Andy，你真是太令人愉快了。
And I hope all is well. And I think maybe I'll be seeing you this summer at the convention. I guess so. At the office convention. Maybe we'll convince someone else to come along. Someone else is going to be doing a play in Chicago. Yeah.
希望一切都好。我想也许今年夏天在大会上能见到你。我想是的。在《办公室》大会上。也许我们会说服别人一起来。别人要在芝加哥演一部戏。是的。
Yes, at that's cool. Yes, at the Goodman. Maybe on your way back. You'll have to stop in Chicago. You should stop in Chicago and see me on stage. Yeah. I'm glad that you're feeling so much better, Jenna. Thank you, I really am.
是的，那太酷了。是的，在Goodman剧院。也许在你回来的路上。你得在芝加哥停一下。你应该在芝加哥停下来看我在舞台上的表演。是的。很高兴你感觉好多了，Jenna。谢谢，我真的感觉好多了。
That obviously could not have been very fun at all, to say the least. So you sound great, and you're doing a play in Chicago. Come on. That's right. At the Goodman. Forget about it. Fancy Chicago theater. I went and saw Steve's play last summer. Oh, Uncle Vanya.
那显然一点也不好玩，至少可以这么说。所以你听起来很棒，而且你要在芝加哥演一部戏。来吧。没错。在Goodman剧院。别提了。高档的芝加哥剧院。去年夏天我去看Steve的戏了。哦，《万尼亚舅舅》。
Uncle Vanya, which was so fun. Yeah. What can't that guy do? He can do it all. But has he been in a Reva McIntyre video? I think not. You know what? I think it was him. He was the guy that was gonna do it. But he insisted on directing. Sounds like Steve. He was probably still like in the,
《万尼亚舅舅》，太有趣了。是的。那家伙有什么不会做的？他什么都能做。但他演过Reba McIntyre的录影带吗？我想没有。你知道吗？我想本来是他。他本来是那个要演的人。但他坚持要导演。听起来像Steve。他可能还在，
that was in like 95 or 96 or something like that. So that was a while ago. I was just gotten out of high school. All right, Andy, big hugs. We love you and thanks so much for chatting with us. I'll chat with you ladies anytime. All right. Thank you.
那是在95或96年左右。所以那是很久以前的事了。我刚高中毕业。好的，Andy，大大的拥抱。我们爱你，非常感谢你和我们聊天。我随时愿意和你们女士聊天。好的。谢谢。
Bye. See you office ladies. Okay, bye. Bye. Bye bye. Well, there you have it. There you have it. I'm so glad he answered the phone
再见。再见，办公室女士们。好的，再见。再见。再见。好吧，就是这样。就是这样。我很高兴他接了电话
because I needed that story today. Also, I need everyone to answer the phone like that needed that story today. Also I need everyone to answer the phone like that when I call them. I know, that was incredible. All right, well everyone, thank you so much for listening to Second Drink. Here is our breakdown of Valentine's Day. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you.
因为我今天需要那个故事。另外，我需要每个人都像那样接电话，当我给他们打电话时。我知道，那太不可思议了。好吧，大家，非常感谢收听《第二杯》。这是我们对《情人节》的解析。我是Jenna Fisher，我是Angela Kinsey。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Today we are talking about the Valentine's Day episode. I am so excited for this one. Me too. I liked this one so much, I watched it an extra time in my prep just for pleasure. I did too.
每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。今天我们要谈论的是《情人节》那一集。我对这一集感到非常兴奋。我也是。我太喜欢这一集了，我在准备时为了享受又多看了一遍。我也看了。
My husband Josh was like, baby, how many times are you going to watch that episode? I was like, I am really enjoying it. I think this one sneaked up on me because there are certain episodes that I remember as being favorites. And this one wasaked up on me because there are certain episodes that I remember as being favorites. And this one was not on my radar. And then I watched it and so many memories came back. So many. Okay, this is a goodie.
我丈夫Josh说，宝贝，你要看那一集多少次？我说，我真的很享受它。我想这一集悄悄地吸引了我，因为有些剧集我记得是我的最爱。而这一集并没有在我的雷达上。然后我看了它，很多回忆涌上心头。太多了。好的，这是一个好东西。
This is season two, episode 16, written by Mike Schur and directed by Greg Daniels. I mean, honestly, that's all you need to know. That's like the super team. Yeah, of course this is a great one. All right, I'll give a summary. It's Valentine's Day at Dunder Mifflin. Michael has to go to the corporate offices in New York. He has to meet and do a presentation for the new CFO, Chief Financial Officer. It's a big deal. It is, and he's going to be there with Jan on Valentine's Day. Oh no. It is, and he's going to be there with Jan on Valentine's Day. Oh, no.
这是第二季第16集，由Mike Schur编剧，Greg Daniels导演。我的意思是，老实说，这就是你需要知道的一切。这就像超级团队。是的，当然这是一部伟大的作品。好吧，我来总结一下。这是Dunder Mifflin的情人节。Michael必须去纽约的公司办公室。他必须会见新的CFO，首席财务官，并进行演示。这是一件大事。是的，他将在情人节那天和Jan在那里。哦，不。
Back at the office, Phyllis is overwhelmed by gifts from her boyfriend, Bob Vance, at Vance Refrigeration. They just come all day, these gifts. All day. Pam patiently waits for a gift from Roy that never comes. No, no. And she really dolled herself up. Oh, yes. That's my fast fact number one, Angela. Do it. Fan question from Baltimore Ashley.
回到办公室，Phyllis被她男朋友Bob Vance（来自Vance Refrigeration）送的礼物淹没了。他们整天都在送，这些礼物。整天。Pam耐心地等待着Roy的礼物，但礼物从未到来。不，不。而且她真的把自己打扮得很漂亮。哦，是的。这是我的第一个快速事实，Angela。说吧。来自巴尔的摩Ashley的粉丝提问。
What was the thought process behind Pam's hair for this episode? Was there another special meeting? I bet there was. Oh, my gosh. You guys, I also got similar questions from Casey McMillan and many other people asking if there was a special meeting for Pam's hair,
这一集中Pam的发型的构思过程是什么？还有其他特别的会议吗？我敢打赌有。哦，天哪。你们，我也收到了来自Casey McMillan和许多其他人的类似问题，问是否有Pam发型的特别会议，
there was more than a meeting. It was like the Joint Chiefs of Staff. It was. Came together for your hair. So the thought process here was that Pam and Jim in this episode, they're gonna be a bit estranged. So wouldn't it be an extra nail in the coffin for Jim if Pam just looked super duper cute?
那不仅仅是一个会议。那就像参谋长联席会议。是的。为了你的头发聚在一起。所以这里的构思过程是，Pam和Jim在这一集中，他们会有点疏远。所以如果Pam看起来超级可爱，对Jim来说不是雪上加霜吗？
Right. So we thought, can we please do something different with her hair? I had a MySpace blog at the time, and I wrote about my hair. Yes. And I said that Kim Ferry and I worked for weeks on different versions of this look. Well, knowing Kim Ferry like I worked for weeks on different versions of this look.
对。所以我们想，能不能请在她的头发上做点不同的事情？当时我有一个MySpace博客，我写了关于我的头发。是的。我说Kim Ferry和我花了几个星期研究这个造型的不同版本。嗯，了解Kim Ferry像我一样，
Well, knowing Kim Ferry like I do, like you do, she must have been so excited because she was so good at hair, but she never got to do much with our hair. No. Okay, so here's what we tried. We tried a ponytail, a barrette, and headbands. We took a picture of each choice and we presented them to Greg Daniels and he went through the photos and had to pick hairstyle and he picked the headband. And there were various headbands. I was going to say, were there 12 different headbands? Yes, yes. So it was, and also ponytails, high pony, low pony, side pony. No side pony.
像你一样，她一定很兴奋，因为她非常擅长发型，但她从来没有机会在我们的头发上做太多事情。不。好吧，这是我们尝试过的。我们尝试了马尾辫、发夹和发带。我们给每个选择拍了一张照片，然后把它们呈现给Greg Daniels，他浏览了照片并不得不选择发型，他选择了发带。而且有各种各样的发带。我正想说，有12种不同的发带吗？是的，是的。所以是，还有马尾辫，高马尾，低马尾，侧马尾。没有侧马尾。
Well, side pony shows up later at the art fair. I wore a side pony tail to my prom. My, I think it was my senior year I did a side pony. I was not cool, guys. You did a side pony to prom? Yeah, I did a side, who? Did you get that done at a salon or did you do that at home?
嗯，侧马尾后来出现在艺术博览会上。我参加舞会时扎过侧马尾。我，我想是我高三那年我扎过侧马尾。我不酷，伙计们。你参加舞会时扎了侧马尾？是的，我扎了侧马尾，谁？你是去沙龙做的还是在家里做的？
No, my mom did it. My mom did it and that was the year. The year before we had all had dates and none of us had a good time, my group of like really close girlfriends. Yeah. So that was the year, the guys thought they were being really cool
不，我妈妈做的。我妈妈做的，那是那一年。前一年我们都有舞伴，但我们都没有玩得开心，我的那群非常亲密的女朋友。是的。所以那一年，男孩子们以为他们很酷，
and they were like, we're not gonna take dates this year. I went to a small school. And so the girls were like, fine. And we had the best time. Was that your senior prom? Our senior prom, I danced in a circle with all my girlfriends with a side ponytail. Lady, I did an all girls prom for my senior prom too.
他们说，我们今年不带舞伴了。我上的是一所小学校。所以女孩子们说，好吧。我们玩得最开心。那是你的毕业舞会吗？我们的毕业舞会，我和我所有的女朋友扎着侧马尾围成一圈跳舞。Lady，我高三时也参加了一个全女生的舞会。
You did, we would have been in the same dance circle. We would have. You would have loved my side pony. I have a card about that fast fact. Tell it. I mean, not only is it Pam's hair, Pam is wearing a pink sweater. Her headband's pink.
你参加了，我们会在同一个舞圈里。我们会。你会喜欢我的侧马尾的。我有一张关于那个快速事实的卡片。说吧。我的意思是，不仅是Pam的头发，Pam穿着一件粉红色的毛衣。她的发带是粉红色的。
She has a heart necklace on. She has pink earrings on. I mean- Little pink dangle earrings. I know. The lady came, like she came to be noticed. She did. She's, I think a little lip gloss.
她戴着心形项链。她戴着粉红色的耳环。我的意思是——小小的粉红色吊坠耳环。我知道。这位女士来了，就像她来是为了被注意到一样。她确实来了。我想还有一点唇彩。
Yes. It was a whole look. I have to say, when I first saw myself on screen, I was a little bit like, oh. Oh, Pam went for it. Pam showed up today. And I mean, it's gonna play out later in the episode, but like, Roy, come on, this is someone who clearly wants a Valentine.
是的。这是一个完整的造型。我不得不说，当我第一次在屏幕上看到自己时，我有点，哦。哦，Pam豁出去了。Pam今天出现了。我的意思是，这会在这一集的后面表现出来，但就像，Roy，拜托，这是一个显然想要情人节礼物的人。
No matter what she says. Okay, sorry, fast fact number two. Fast fact number two, a portion of this episode was shot in New York City. We got a lot of fan questions about this. People wanted to know if we did Steve stand in front of a green screen? Did we shoot on the streets of Los Angeles? No.
不管她说什么。好的，抱歉，第二个快速事实。第二个快速事实，这一集的一部分是在纽约市拍摄的。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。人们想知道我们是否让Steve站在绿幕前？我们在洛杉矶的街道上拍摄了吗？没有。
But there's more questions, Angela. Fan question from Cora Louise, how many crew members came to New York City? And Guava Aora asked, how long did it take to shoot this episode in New York and was the rest of the cast in California? Yes. We did not get to go. We did not. We were all pretty bummed
但还有更多问题，Angela。来自Cora Louise的粉丝提问，有多少剧组成员去了纽约市？Guava Aora问，在纽约拍摄这一集花了多长时间，其他演员在加利福尼亚吗？是的。我们没能去。我们没有。我们都很沮丧，
because it sounded like so much fun. So I reached out to Randall Einhorn, our director of photography. Jenna, you know I did this. I know and you guys, she wouldn't tell me what he said. She's got all this good information about the New York shoot and she made me wait. Well, this is I did this. I know. And you guys, she wouldn't tell me what he said. She's got all this good information about the New York shoot, and she made me wait. Well, this is something we do.
因为听起来太有趣了。所以我联系了我们的摄影指导Randall Einhorn。Jenna，你知道我这么做了。我知道，你们，她不告诉我他说了什么。她有所有关于纽约拍摄的好信息，她让我等。嗯，这是我做的。我知道。而且你们，她不告诉我他说了什么。她有所有关于纽约拍摄的好信息，她让我等。嗯，这是我们做的事情。
We both love to dig up nuggets of info, and then we don't tell each other because we want the surprise. I know. So I've been waiting like five days for this. OK. Here we go. So I reached out to Randall, and he
我们都喜欢挖掘信息碎片，然后我们不告诉对方，因为我们想要惊喜。我知道。所以我已经等了五天了。好的。我们开始吧。所以我联系了Randall，他
said the crew in New York was just him and Greg and Steve. That would go out on the street when they would film. And in the van, they had, I think think two crew members that were New York based like because they had to do things by the rules, you know, and our line producer Kent Zabornak. But whenever the van doors would open, it would just be Greg, Steve and Randall. He said that this was right at the height of 40 year old Virgin. It was the biggest movie in America. He said there was a billboard in Times Square
说纽约的剧组只有他和Greg还有Steve。当他们拍摄时，他们会走到街上。在货车里，我想有两个基于纽约的剧组成员，因为他们必须按规则办事，你知道，还有我们的制片经理Kent Zabornak。但每当货车门打开时，就只有Greg、Steve和Randall。他说这正值《四十岁的老处男》最火的时候。那是美国最大的电影。他说时代广场有一个广告牌，
where they were filming. So he said the minute Steve would get out of the van, a crowd would form. So he said they had to move really fast and quickly. And he said he used a handy cam camera, like a basic handy cam camera that you could buy at Costco. Whoa. It's a really small camera,
他们就在那里拍摄。所以他说Steve一从货车里出来，人群就会聚集。所以他说他们必须移动得非常快。他说他用了一台手持摄像机，就像你在Costco能买到的那种基本手持摄像机。哇。那是一台非常小的摄像机，
so not to draw a lot of attention to them. Yeah. Because the minute people saw Steve, literally he said a crowd would form. Well, wasn't this also right after his Golden Globe win? Oh yes, yes, it was all of that. He just won the Golden Globe, there was a billboard of him in Times Square,
所以不会引起太多对他们的注意。是的。因为人们一看到Steve，他说真的，人群就会聚集。嗯，这不也是在他获得金球奖之后吗？哦，是的，是的，就是这一切。他刚赢得了金球奖，时代广场上有他的广告牌，
and they're gonna film on the streets of New York. Bonkers. Bonkers. Now this was scripted though. They had certain scripted spots, but I know that Steve was also improvising and riffing at the same time. It was very loosey goosey.
他们要在纽约的街道上拍摄。疯了。疯了。现在这是有剧本的。他们有一些特定的剧本点，但我知道Steve同时也在即兴发挥。非常随意。
That's true, that's true. So I asked Randall, okay, what were some of the things that you know were scripted? He said the Rockefeller Center portion was scripted. He said that Sabaro was scripted, but he said that he's pretty sure when Steve goes into the subway and sees a man pooping in the box that that was improv. That was Steve just goofing around. But Steve did a lot of improv. Like whenever they saw something or they had a moment he would hop out, you know, there's a tag at the end of like the fiddler on the roof, like him goofing around. That's improv. There's a bunch of deleted scenes of him on the streets of New York that I think
那是真的，那是真的。所以我问Randall，好的，你知道哪些是有剧本的？他说洛克菲勒中心的部分是有剧本的。他说Sabaro是有剧本的，但他非常确定当Steve走进地铁看到一个男人在盒子里大便时，那是即兴表演。那是Steve在胡闹。但Steve做了很多即兴表演。就像每当他们看到什么东西或者他们有一个时刻，他就会跳出来，你知道，最后有一个像《屋顶上的提琴手》那样的标签，就像他胡闹一样。那是即兴表演。有很多关于他在纽约街头的删减片段，我认为
are a lot of improvisations. They're fantastic. The deleted scenes for this are great, and I'll bring up some more of them later. And then I said, Randall, is there like a fun story or a memory you have from filming in New York that maybe doesn't even have anything to do with the episode? And he said, yes.
有很多即兴表演。它们太棒了。这一集的删减片段很棒，我稍后会提到更多。然后我说，Randall，你有什么关于在纽约拍摄的有趣故事或记忆吗，也许甚至和这一集无关？他说，是的。
This is what he said. He said, the night they got into New York, just him and Steve went to this place called Johnny's and they got beer and pizza. He said he thought the pizza was pepperoni. But he just said it was really special and they were walking back to their hotel, walking through Times Square.
他是这么说的。他说，他们到达纽约的那天晚上，只有他和Steve去了这个叫Johnny's的地方，他们喝了啤酒，吃了披萨。他说他以为披萨是意大利辣香肠的。但他只是说这真的很特别，他们走回酒店，穿过时代广场。
And he said, there were billboards everywhere. A 40 year old virgin with Steve's face, like all over the place. And the show is getting popular. Steve had just won a Golden Globe. So it was kind of surreal to walk through all of those billboards of Steve. And people started coming up to Steve and Randall said that Steve was as gracious and kind to the first person who stopped him as he was to the 100th.
他说，到处都是广告牌。《四十岁的老处男》上有Steve的脸，到处都是。而且这部剧越来越受欢迎。Steve刚赢得了金球奖。所以走过所有那些Steve的广告牌感觉有点超现实。人们开始走近Steve，Randall说Steve对第一个拦住他的人和对第一百个人一样亲切和友善。
He just was so kind and in the moment. But that is Steve. He was so kind and in the moment. But that is Steve, you know? He is so kind and gracious. And Randall just said it was really special, I think, for him and Steve to just have that night together like that. Yeah. Just grabbing a slice and a beer and being in New York, I'm sure it felt really cool. Aw, I love that. I know, me too. That's one of the cool things about the show where there's some circumstance that brings you to an experience you would not have normally had. Yeah, yeah. So cool.
他就是那么友善，活在当下。但那就是Steve。他就是那么友善，活在当下。但那就是Steve，你知道吗？他就是那么友善和亲切。Randall只是说，我想对他和Steve来说，能有那样一个夜晚在一起真的很特别。是的。只是吃一片披萨，喝杯啤酒，在纽约，我敢肯定感觉真的很酷。啊，我喜欢那个。我知道，我也是。这是这部剧很酷的事情之一，有一些情况把你带到了一种你通常不会有的体验中。是的，是的。太酷了。
So cool. And Greg and Kincebornak talk a little bit more about New York in the DVD commentary, so if you want to give that a listen. All right, Jenna, that's my New York City nuggets. They were great and they were worth waiting for. Thank you. I loved for. Thank you. I loved them. Thank you.
太酷了。Greg和Kincebornak在DVD评论中谈论了更多关于纽约的事情，所以如果你想听听那个。好吧，Jenna，这就是我的纽约市小知识。它们很棒，值得等待。谢谢。我喜欢它们。谢谢。
Fast fact number three. In this episode, we meet the new CFO of Dunder Mifflin, David Wallace. Hey now. Hey, who's here? Who's here? Brased by Andy Buckley. There we go.
第三个快速事实。在这一集中，我们见到了Dunder Mifflin的新CFO，David Wallace。嘿，现在。嘿，谁在这儿？谁在这儿？由Andy Buckley扮演。我们来了。
Who's in studio with us now. I'm gonna put on the Wallace glasses. Put on the Wallace glasses. Andy, you appeared in 37 episodes of the show. Yep. 37. That's crazy, yeah. Here's some stuff I learned about you by looking you up on the internet.
现在和我们在录音室里。我要戴上Wallace眼镜。戴上Wallace眼镜。Andy，你出演了37集这部剧。是的。37集。太疯狂了，是的。这是我通过在互联网上搜索你了解到的关于你的一些事情。
Well, get ready. We should say the three of us are friends in real life. So it was a little bit interesting to Google a friend. But here's some things I learned about you. None of it is true. Oh, boy. But it's probably all true. That's good to know. It's probably to Google a friend, but here's some things I learned about you. None of it is true. Oh boy. But it's probably all true. That's good to know.
好吧，准备好。我们应该说我们三个人在现实生活中是朋友。所以谷歌搜索一个朋友有点意思。但这是我了解到的关于你的一些事情。没有一个是真的。哦，天哪。但可能都是真的。很高兴知道。
It's probably all true. You were born in Boston. Yup, Salem, Massachusetts, grew up in Marblehead, Swampskate, Peabody, mostly Marblehead, and I have the SmartPak. You do? SmartPak, Sean Krasinski, SmartPak. You graduated from Stanford University, but you got a degree in political science. Yes.
可能都是真的。你出生在波士顿。是的，Salem，马萨诸塞州，在Marblehead、Swampskate、Peabody长大，主要是Marblehead，我有SmartPak。你有吗？SmartPak，Sean Krasinski，SmartPak。你毕业于斯坦福大学，但你获得了政治学学位。是的。
Not theater, not acting. No. So I was a golfer in high school and I went there to play golf. Like I was on the golf team. Like on a golf scholarship? Yeah. They didn't have a ton of money, but I got in through the golf program and they gave you a thousand bucks.
不是戏剧，不是表演。不。所以我高中时是高尔夫球手，我去那里打高尔夫。就像我在高尔夫球队一样。就像高尔夫奖学金？是的。他们没有很多钱，但我通过高尔夫项目进去了，他们给了我一千块钱。
Hold up. That means you're a good golfer. I used to be. I'm still good, but I got in through the golf program and they gave you a thousand bucks. You're a good golfer. I used to be. I'm still good, but I used to be. But yes, and I was a polysciamator. I did plays there and I had done plays in high school also and loved acting and saw a James Dean movie when I was in high school and thought I was going to be like a brooding young. Brooding, golf playing, James Dean yeah. All of the above. James Dean, political science.
等等。那意味着你是个高尔夫好手。我曾经是。我现在仍然很好，但我通过高尔夫项目进去了，他们给了我一千块钱。你是个高尔夫好手。我曾经是。但我曾经是。但是的，我是政治学专业的。我在那里演过戏，我在高中也演过戏，热爱表演，我在高中时看过一部James Dean的电影，以为我会成为一个忧郁的年轻人。忧郁的，打高尔夫的，James Dean，是的。以上皆是。James Dean，政治学。
And none of it worked. But when you were cast on the show, you were working as a wealth management advisor, which I believe is a fancy word for stockbroker. That's exactly it, yeah. At Merrill Lynch. Yes, I study acting. I moved to Los Angeles.
而且没有一个奏效。但当你被选中出演这部剧时，你正在担任财富管理顾问，我相信这是股票经纪人的华丽说法。完全正确，是的。在美林证券。是的，我学习表演。我搬到了洛杉矶。
It does not go well for the first like seven or eight or nine years. I get little bits and pieces here. Allison Jones being possibly my only fan, luckily. And my wife, who was then my girlfriend, said, you got to, you got to change it up. This is crazy. Like you can't just keep doing these odd jobs and then think you're gonna get hired. She was like, get a job. Get a job, literally, basically get a job. And there was an old acting buddy of mine
前七、八、九年过得并不顺利。我在这里得到一点点小角色。Allison Jones可能是我的唯一粉丝，幸运的是。我的妻子，当时还是我的女朋友，说，你得，你得改变一下。这太疯狂了。就像你不能一直做这些零工，然后认为你会得到聘用。她说，找份工作。找份工作，字面上，基本上找份工作。我有一个老演戏的朋友
who was working there and he would still audition. He said, oh, come interview, I might be great for you. And they hire me and I loved it, it was crazy, I loved it. So I started there in 2001 and was there and that's all I was doing and then we got married and we had our first son I bumped into Allison Jones. We're like the local farmers market on Larchmont and you're you're Just a guy getting up and being in the office at six and talking to clients or you know potential clients or and And I see her and what are you doing? Buckley? I haven't seen you in a while. I'm like, well, stockbroker, I'm married, I got a kid, I'm like Mr. Grown-up. And she says, well, give me your card just
他在那里工作，他还会去试镜。他说，哦，来面试吧，我可能对你很棒。他们雇了我，我喜欢它，太疯狂了，我喜欢它。所以我2001年开始在那里工作，一直待在那里，这就是我所做的一切，然后我们结婚了，我们有了第一个儿子，我碰到了Allison Jones。我们就像在Larchmont的当地农贸市场，你只是一个早上起床，六点钟在办公室和客户或你知道潜在客户交谈的人，或者我看到她，你在做什么？Buckley？我有一段时间没见你了。我说，嗯，股票经纪人，我结婚了，我有孩子，我就像个成年人先生。她说，好吧，给我你的名片，以防
in case something comes up. You never know. I mean, would you want to do it? I guess if it's in town. And without her mentioning anything or thinking, you never know. I mean, would you want to do it? I guess if it's in town and without her mentioning anything or thinking, you know, four months almost later, she calls me. It's like Buckley, I can't believe I found this card, but I'm glad I did. I think you might be the right guy. You should come audition for this, you know, the boss on the office. You know, the show and yeah, of course I know the show. Like, yeah, he's the financial guy and you're a financial guy. They might like that. You should audition.
万一有什么事。你永远不知道。我的意思是，你想做吗？我想如果是在城里的话。而且她没有提到任何事情或思考，你永远不知道。我的意思是，你想做吗？我想如果是在城里的话，而且她没有提到任何事情或思考，你知道，几乎四个月后，她给我打电话。就像Buckley，我不敢相信我找到了这张名片，但我很高兴我找到了。我想你可能是合适的人选。你应该来为这个试镜，你知道，办公室里的老板。你知道，这部剧，是的，我当然知道这部剧。就像，是的，他是财务主管，而你是财务主管。他们可能会喜欢那个。你应该试镜。
And it was great. I go, I, so I go in and say hi, do the first scene. But I read with Alison, it was Mike Schur in the room and it was just the two of them. So I read with Alison, I do the first scene and then the second scene. And then Michael says, now you're, you're like, you're a finance, what are you,
这太棒了。我去，我进去，打个招呼，做第一场戏。但我读了Alison的剧本，Mike Schur在房间里，只有他们两个。所以我读了Alison的剧本，我做了第一场戏，然后是第二场戏。然后Michael说，现在你，你就像，你是一个财务，你是什么，
you're like some kind of financial guy, right? Now knowing Mike the way we know Mike, he loved that. I know that he loved that, that you were actually working at Merrill Lynch was probably one of the coolest things to him. I figure that's why I got hired. And then I go back to my office and I'm like, all right. And you just go about your day.
你就像某种财务人员，对吧？现在像我们了解Mike那样了解Mike，他喜欢那个。我知道他喜欢那个，你实际上在美林证券工作对他来说可能是最酷的事情之一。我想这就是我被雇用的原因。然后我回到我的办公室，我想，好吧。然后你继续你的一天。
And then the next morning, Alison calls and says, hey, they're going to hire you. I was so excited. It was like, oh man, this will be awesome. At the time I thought, well, maybe this will be cool. I'll get to be on the show once a year or something like that or twice. I mean, that'll be fun.
然后第二天早上，Alison打电话说，嘿，他们要雇用你。我太兴奋了。就像，哦，伙计，这会很棒。当时我想，嗯，也许这会很酷。我一年能上一次节目或者类似的东西，或者两次。我的意思是，那会很有趣。
Yeah. I was going to ask you, when you auditioned, did they say this was one episode with the possibility of more, or did they give you any indication that this might lead to 37 episodes? No, they didn't say anything. And I mean, that was it. It was so whatever day the audition was,
是的。我正要问你，当你试镜时，他们说这是一集，有可能有更多，还是他们给了你任何迹象表明这可能会导致37集？不，他们什么也没说。我的意思是，就是这样。试镜是哪一天，
and then the next week, I guess, I did it. Now, where did you film the boardroom scenes? My memory is that it was right next to our Dunder Mifflin set that you could walk from our set to your set. Right. That's that's what it was. Yeah. So you were just right there. I was right there and I show up and Steve couldn't have been nicer. Everybody, you know, everybody couldn't have been nicer.
然后下周，我想，我做了。现在，你在哪里拍摄董事会场景？我的记忆是它就在我们的Dunder Mifflin布景旁边，你可以从我们的布景走到你的布景。对。那就是它。是的。所以你就在那儿。我就在那儿，我出现了，Steve再好不过了。每个人，你知道，每个人再好不过了。
And and and and it was just it was fun because Greg would come up and he would say, great, that was good. Okay. And they said, let's try it this way. And he would have an idea, which I can't, I was trying to think like, what were his specific ideas? And it was along the lines of like, do this one as if you just want to keep things calm. Do this one as if you're a little irritated. Just sort of subtle changes. This is in the great Scott, you know, when he shows the video. Oh my goodness. You guys, your facial reactions to the video that Michael makes is so amazing. It was so wonderful. So when do you get the call that they want you back for another episode?
而且这很有趣，因为Greg会走过来，他会说，太棒了，那很好。好的。他们说，让我们试试这种方式。他会有一个想法，我不能，我试图想，他的具体想法是什么？这就像，做这一场，就好像你只是想保持冷静。做这一场，就好像你有点恼火。只是某种微妙的变化。这是在伟大的Scott，你知道，当他展示视频时。哦，天哪。你们，你们对Michael制作的视频的面部反应太棒了。太美妙了。那么你什么时候接到电话说他们想让你回来拍另一集？
A year later. A year later. A year later. A year later. Oh my gosh, Andy. Oh, it's great. Allison calls and says, Buckley, you're in an episode in a couple of weeks and you're all over it like you're having a party at your house. Everybody's there. It's crazy. And she's like, and JJ Abrams is directing like it's crazy.
一年后。一年后。一年后。一年后。哦，天哪，Andy。哦，太棒了。Allison打电话说，Buckley，几周后你有一集，你到处都是，就像你在家里开派对一样。每个人都在那儿。太疯狂了。她说，JJ Abrams在导演，太疯狂了。
You're like, wait, I have some meetings I have to rearrange. I'm going gotta change around. But it was after we hired Ryan at the very end of season three that I kind of thought, oh, maybe I'll get to be on this like two or three times. He's like, we're coming to corporate. He's coming to corporate. Maybe I'll get to be on it.
你就像，等等，我有一些会议必须重新安排。我得改变一下。但在第三季末我们雇用了Ryan之后，我有点想，哦，也许我能上这个节目两三次。他说，我们要去公司。他要来公司。也许我能上节目。
You could see a possible storyline. I thought, yeah, like, oh, wow. Do you get recognized a lot? Do people scream suck it at you? Yes. And then do recognized a lot? Do people scream suck it at you? Yes. And then do other people wonder why people are screaming suck it at you? It's funny.
你可以看到一个可能的故事线。我想，是的，就像，哦，哇。你经常被认出来吗？人们会对你尖叫“Suck it”吗？是的。然后其他人会想为什么人们会对你尖叫“Suck it”吗？这很有趣。
And I definitely haven't sometimes. And all of this has started to happen so much more in the last three or four years because of Netflix and the show is so much bigger and everything. Andy, do you still work at Merrill Lynch? No. So I left. The last season of the show was when I finally left.
我肯定有时没有。所有这些在过去三四年里开始发生得更多，因为Netflix和这部剧大得多，等等。Andy，你还在美林证券工作吗？不。所以我离开了。这部剧的最后一季是我最终离开的时候。
Well, you've gone on to do a bunch of stuff now. You're now a full-time actor. What are you working on right now? Can we tell people where to find you now? Super, super lucky. So let's see. So I get to be on a cast once again by Alison Jones, this HBO show called Avenue 5, which is super funny.
嗯，你现在已经做了很多事情了。你现在是一名全职演员。你现在在做什么？我们可以告诉人们现在在哪里找到你吗？超级，超级幸运。让我们看看。所以我再次被Alison Jones选中，这部HBO剧叫《Avenue 5》，超级有趣。
And it's the fellow that wrote, created Veep. It's his new show. We're on this crazy, you know, we're on a cruise ship, luxury cruise ship in outer space. Like it's, it's just a cruise ship, but it's 30 years from now. So we're in space as if Elon Musk or Richard Branson. Right, right, had finally figured it out.
这是写《副总统》的那个人，他创作的。这是他的新剧。我们在这一部疯狂的，你知道，我们在游轮上，外太空的豪华游轮。就像它，它只是一艘游轮，但那是30年后的事了。所以我们在太空中，就像Elon Musk或Richard Branson。对，对，终于弄明白了。
And Hugh Laurie is the captain of the ship. Oh my gosh. And Josh Gann, and Zach Woods is on it. It's great because uh, oh my goodness is he so funny because I never acted with him. Like basically he came in as I was He is so funny. He's so funny. And he's so smart. He's so smart. Thank you so so much. Thank you for coming. You guys can find Andy on Instagram as well and Twitter. You've got quite a nice Twitter. Tell us your handle. I'm at just Andy Buckley and then on Instagram I am Andy Buckley 2020 in case I decide to
Hugh Laurie是船长。哦，天哪。Josh Gann，Zach Woods也在上面。这太棒了，因为呃，哦，天哪，他太有趣了，因为我从来没和他演过戏。就像基本上他进来的时候我正在，他太有趣了。他太有趣了。而且他太聪明了。他太聪明了。非常非常感谢。谢谢你来。你们也可以在Instagram和Twitter上找到Andy。你的Twitter很不错。告诉我们你的账号。我是@justAndyBuckley，然后在Instagram上我是AndyBuckley2020，以防我决定
run for an office. Great. But just for this year. Just for this year. Well, I am following you Andy Buckley 2020 on the Insta. I appreciate it. We're Insta pals. I appreciate it.
竞选公职。太棒了。但只是今年。只是今年。嗯，我正在Instagram上关注你AndyBuckley2020。我很感激。我们是Instagram伙伴。我很感激。
I know. And you'll have to come back. You'll have to come back. Yeah, you do have 36 more episodes. Yeah. And we've only really covered your origin story. So there's more to talk about. All right, Andy, thank you so much. Thank you very much.
我知道。你得回来。你得回来。是的，你还有36集。是的。而且我们真的只涵盖了你的起源故事。所以还有更多要谈的。好的，Andy，非常感谢。非常感谢。
Thank you for having me, ladies. ["The Daily Show Theme"] Some people play it safe, but that's never been my style. I'm Soraya, and this is Roll Breakers, the podcast where we celebrate the rebels, the misfits, and the ones who make their own way. Every week I sit down with athletes, entertainers, and industry disruptors who don't just push the boundaries now. They shatter them. We talk about the wildest risks they've taken, the lessons they've learned, and the moments
谢谢你们邀请我，女士们。["The Daily Show Theme"] 有些人选择安全，但这从来不是我的风格。我是Soraya，这是《Rule Breakers》，这个播客我们庆祝叛逆者、不合群者和那些走出自己道路的人。每周我都会和运动员、艺人和行业颠覆者坐下来，他们不仅现在推动界限。他们打破了界限。我们谈论他们冒过的最疯狂的风险，他们学到的教训，以及那些
that made them who they are. No fillers. No BS. Just real talk with people who refuse to follow the script. And we don't just talk about breaking the rules now. We prove it. Think dog shot collars, bug trivia, blindfold tattoos, and text roulette.
造就了他们的时刻。没有填充物。没有废话。只是和那些拒绝遵循剧本的人进行真正的交谈。我们不仅谈论打破规则。我们证明了它。想想狗的电击项圈、虫子琐事、蒙眼纹身和短信轮盘赌。
The stakes are high and the chaos is real. So if you've ever been told to stay in your lane, this show is for you. Follow and listen to Rule Breakers with Serea, an Odyssey podcast available now for free on the Odyssey app and wherever you get your podcasts. the Odyssey app and wherever you get your podcasts. And we're back. Hello.
赌注很高，混乱是真实的。所以如果你曾经被告知要待在自己的车道上，这个节目就是为你准备的。关注并收听Serea的《Rule Breakers》，一个Odyssey播客，现在可以在Odyssey应用程序上免费收听，无论你在哪里获取你的播客。我们回来了。你好。
Let's start breaking down the Valentine's Day episode. Let's get into it, lady. All right. So we start with a Pam talking head. She explains it's Valentine's Day. This is not your typical cold open where it's a standalone kind of prank or joke. This applies to the story of the episode. We noted earlier, her hair is down. She's got her sparkly headband on. She actually says, I like Valentine's Day
让我们开始拆解情人节这一集吧。我们开始吧，女士。好的。所以我们从帕姆的采访镜头开始。她解释说今天是情人节。这不像通常那种独立的恶作剧或笑话的冷开场。这与本集的剧情有关。我们之前注意到，她的头发披散着。她戴着闪亮的头带。她实际上说，我喜欢办公室里的情人节。
in this office. Yeah, because we all hand things out to each other. She talks about how last year Jim gave her a card, a hilarious card with Dwight's face on it. It was so funny. But then she says that her and Roy are saving money this year for the wedding. So she told him not to get anything too big. Too big, but she's still clearly expecting something. She still wants something. Well, I have a few little background things for this talking head. Okay. That I found very interesting. Yes. So behind our talking heads was normally you could see Leslie David Baker, who plays Stanley, our Phyllis. Yeah. At their desks. You would never see Jim behind you during a talking head because his desk is over closer to Pam's at reception.
是啊，因为我们都会互相分发东西。她谈到去年吉姆给了她一张卡片，一张印着德怀特脸的搞笑卡片。那太搞笑了。但随后她说她和罗伊今年为了婚礼在存钱。所以她告诉他不要买太贵重的东西。太贵重，但她显然还是期待着什么。她还是想要点什么。嗯，关于这个采访镜头，我有一些背景小知识。好的。我觉得非常有趣。是的。在我们的采访镜头后面，通常你可以看到饰演斯坦利的莱斯利·大卫·贝克，或者菲利斯。是的。在他们的办公桌前。你永远不会在采访镜头后面看到吉姆，因为他的桌子离帕姆的前台更近。
Is Jim in the background of this? Jim is in the background of your talking head. He's like sitting over there talking to Creed. You can see him in the distance. And I was listening to the DVD commentary. And one of the things that Greg and Mike talked about was in this episode, Jim and Pam barely speak. But they're always in the foreground or background of each other's shots.
吉姆在这一幕的背景里吗？吉姆在你的采访镜头背景里。他坐在那边和克里德说话。你可以在远处看到他。我当时在听DVD评论音轨。格雷格和迈克谈到的一件事是，在这一集中，吉姆和帕姆几乎没有说话。但他们总是出现在彼此镜头的远景或背景中。
That was sort of a conscious thing. When they could have one of you in the background they would. That is so interesting because I noticed that in the background of Jim's talking head later, Pam is delivering Phyllis a little piece of candy. Yes. So see, this was thought out. Now, there's one other thing I want to point out because in the deleted scenes, Oscar at the top of the episode is handing out Valentines. And this is footage behind your talking head. You say, I like Valentines at this office. We hand out cards and things.
这算是一种有意识的安排。当他们能把你们其中一人放在背景里时，他们就会这样做。这太有趣了，因为我注意到在后来吉姆的采访镜头背景里，帕姆正在给菲利斯分发一小块糖果。是的。所以你看，这是经过深思熟虑的。现在，还有一件事我想指出，因为在删减片段中，奥斯卡在这一集开头正在分发情人节卡片。这就是你采访镜头背后的画面。你说，我喜欢办公室里的情人节。我们分发卡片之类的东西。
Yeah. You see Oscar passing out these little red hearts. Well, it's a great deleted scene. He hands one to Creed. Creed is getting off the phone where he calls a guy Ace and then he says to Oscar, thanks Ace. And then he has a talking head where he's like, yeah, I'm not good with names. I don't know. He doesn't know people's names. So that was actually a scene that then they repurposed and used for the backdrop of your talking head. Oh my gosh,
是的。你可以看到奥斯卡在分发这些小红心。嗯，这是一个很棒的删减片段。他递给克里德一个。克里德当时刚挂断电话，他称呼对方为“王牌”，然后他对奥斯卡说，谢谢你，王牌。然后他有一个采访镜头，他说，是的，我不擅长记名字。我不知道。他不认识人们的名字。所以那实际上是一个后来被重新利用，用作你采访镜头背景的场景。天哪，
that is a great catch. Yeah. And then I think just before we get into this episode, I would love to give a little props to the party planning committee because you know they were in charge of decorating the office. Yeah. Did you see all the Valentine stuff? I did. Fan catch from Izzy Garragan. She said around 22 seconds, Pam has a football plush on her desk, but I noticed that she has Valentine's Day themed candy.
那真是个很棒的发现。是的。然后我想在进入这一集之前，我很想给派对策划委员会一点赞美，因为你知道他们负责装饰办公室。是的。你看到所有的情人节装饰了吗？我看到了。来自伊兹·加拉根的粉丝发现。她说在大约22秒时，帕姆的桌上有一个橄榄球毛绒玩具，但我注意到她有情人节主题的糖果。
She has a cup of pins and a Valentine's Day cup on the top of her desk. And the cups are even sort of like red pins. Yes, and then she even had, there's all these like decorations on the front of reception. She's got like a Valentine's Day poster and there's a heart shaped candy dish, there's red jelly beans, there's like a little squishy heart dude on the front of reception. She's got like a Valentine's Day poster and there's a heart shaped candy dish.
她的桌上有一个插着大头针的杯子和一个情人节杯子。杯子甚至看起来有点像红色的针。是的，然后她甚至在接待处的前面有各种装饰。她有一个情人节海报，还有一个心形的糖果盘，有红色的软糖豆，接待处前面还有一个软软的心形小人。她有一个情人节海报，还有一个心形的糖果盘。
There's red jelly beans. There's like a little squishy heart dude on top of the jelly beans. Over by accounting, there's heart garland. There's a heart poster. There's some heart garland over on the supply cabinet. So the ladies really- We did a good job.
有红色的软糖豆。软糖豆上面还有一个软软的心形小人。在会计部那边，有心形花环。有一个心形海报。在储物柜上也有一些心形花环。所以女士们真的——我们做得很好。
They went all out, buy all out. They put up two posters. It's still within their budget. But it was fairly decorated, I will say. They went all out, buy all out, they put up two posters. It's still within their budget. But it was fairly decorated, I will say. I noticed as well. All right, so next up, Phyllis gets a giant bouquet of roses. Did you catch the card? It made me laugh out loud.
她们全力以赴，真的是全力以赴。她们贴了两张海报。这还在她们的预算之内。但我得说，装饰得相当不错。她们全力以赴，真的是全力以赴，她们贴了两张海报。这还在她们的预算之内。但我得说，装饰得相当不错。我也注意到了。好的，接下来，菲利斯收到了一大束玫瑰花。你看到卡片了吗？它让我大笑出声。
No, what was it? The flowers are from Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. Oh yes, yes, yes, I did catch that. Just that Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration was part of the card was part of the card that that does make me laugh I don't know about you, but my husband when he gives me a gift like his card skills, babe. I love you I okay first of all, I appreciate the thought but for Valentine's his card said to my wife from your husband And it was like flowers and it was really sweet but that's all the card said, to my wife from your husband. And it was like flowers and it was really sweet, but that's all the card said. So we find out now that Michael is heading to New York
没有，写了什么？花是鲍勃·万斯送的，万斯制冷公司。哦，是的，是的，是的，我确实注意到了。仅仅是“鲍勃·万斯，万斯制冷公司”作为卡片的一部分，这确实让我发笑。我不知道你怎么样，但我丈夫给我送礼物时，他的卡片技巧，宝贝。我爱你，我，好吧，首先，我很感激这份心意，但情人节他的卡片上写着“致我的妻子，来自你的丈夫”。就像花一样，真的很甜，但卡片上只写了这些，“致我的妻子，来自你的丈夫”。就像花一样，真的很甜，但卡片上只写了这些。所以我们现在发现迈克尔正前往纽约
to do a presentation about this grant branch for the new CFO. And we know this is important because there have been rumors of downsizing. And so Michael has to really prove the worth of this branch so that no one gets fired. In this scene he packs his passport. For a two and a half hour drive guys. For a drive. It's a two and a half hour drive. Not even flying. Not going across the border. Nope. Passport. Got it. Dwight asks if he's excited to see Jan
去为新任首席财务官做一个关于这个分公司的演讲。我们知道这很重要，因为一直有裁员的传言。所以迈克尔必须真正证明这个分公司的价值，这样才不会有人被解雇。在这一幕中，他打包了他的护照。为了一个两个半小时的车程，伙计们。为了开车。这是一个两个半小时的车程。甚至不是坐飞机。不是要过边境。不。护照。拿到了。德怀特问他是否很兴奋见到简，
because it is Valentine's Day. And then Michael has a talking head where he says, I would have to be a raving lunatic to try to talk to Jan about what happened between us. Her words, not mine. She sent me an email this morning. I loved that. I love that so much. Also, did you notice right after his passport, Dwight hands him what looks like, it looks
因为今天是情人节。然后迈克尔有一个采访镜头，他说，如果我试图和简谈论我们之间发生的事情，那我一定是个疯子。她的话，不是我的。她今天早上给我发了封邮件。我喜欢那个。我太喜欢那个了。还有，你注意到在他拿出护照后，德怀特递给他看起来像，看起来
like a Blackberry. Do we have some old tech, some old tech catch there? Ooh, old tech catch. Old tech catch, I can't even say that. Old tech catch. Old tech catch, okay. As Michael is leaving, he asks Pam if he can pick her up anything in New York.
像个黑莓手机吗？我们这里有一些旧科技的发现吗？哦，旧科技发现。旧科技发现，我甚至说不出来。旧科技发现。旧科技发现，好的。迈克尔离开时，他问帕姆在纽约能不能帮她带点什么。
I love Oscar's response. Because Oscar's like the dad. He's kind of the dad. He's like, you know, the best gift would be just do a good job on the presentation so we can all keep our jobs. Yeah, thanks a lot. Thanks a lot. And Michael's like me in New York. Oh, I own that city. Forget about it. Yeah. You have to go back and look at Oscar's face. Oh my God. It's so good. If that's not a meme, it should be that that
我喜欢奥斯卡的回答。因为奥斯卡就像个爸爸。他有点像爸爸。他说，你知道，最好的礼物就是把演讲做好，这样我们大家都能保住工作。是的，多谢了。多谢了。迈克尔说，我在纽约。哦，我拥有那座城市。别提了。是的。你得回去看看奥斯卡的表情。天哪。太棒了。如果那不是个表情包，它就应该成为一个。
should be. So then we have our opening credits. And when those are over, Michael is driving to New York. No need for a passport. Two and a half hour drive. Don't need it. Within the continental United States. Still don't need it. And then Jim has a talking head where he tells us
应该成为。所以接下来是片头字幕。结束后，迈克尔正开车去纽约。不需要护照。两个半小时的车程。不需要。在美国本土内。还是不需要。然后吉姆有一个采访镜头，他告诉我们
that he is not dating anyone and he's just gonna have like a party with his buddies. Well, what the heck happened to Brenda? I don't know. He's not dating anyone. He left Brenda that ridiculously awkward voicemail. I guess that didn't work out. I guess it didn't.
他没有和任何人约会，他只是打算和他的哥们儿开个派对。好吧，布伦达到底怎么了？我不知道。他没有和任何人约会。他给布伦达留了那个极其尴尬的语音留言。我想那没成。我想是的。
Now, during his talking head, you can kind of get a glimpse at Pam's wedding invite list. Yeah, there's a shot of Pam at her desk, and I had a fan question about it. OK, you know I did a screen grab and tried my best to read every name. Oh, I want to hear what they are. Louisa J said, are the names on the wedding invite list
现在，在他的采访镜头中，你可以瞥见帕姆的婚礼邀请名单。是的，有一个帕姆在桌前的镜头，我有一个关于它的粉丝问题。好的，你知道我截了图，尽我所能读出每一个名字。哦，我想听听都是些什么。路易莎·J说，婚礼邀请名单上的名字是
characters or made up or based on real life people? Now, I was looking at some of these names and part of it looked like, like maybe Phil Shea had started the list, but it looked like you had added to it during the scene. Yes, the typed list was provided to me by Phil Shea. Yes. The handwritten list are the names of my real aunts and uncles and cousins. I was going to say I saw Emily, which is your sister. Yep. So I was like, as I screen grabbed it, I was like, Oh, Jenna
角色，还是虚构的，或者是基于现实生活中的人？现在，我看着其中一些名字，部分看起来，就像也许菲尔·谢开始了这份名单，但看起来你在那一幕中又添加了一些。是的，打印的名单是菲尔·谢提供给我的。是的。手写的名单是我真正的阿姨、叔叔和表亲的名字。我正想说我看到了艾米丽，那是你的姐妹。是的。所以我当时想，当我截图时，我想，哦，珍娜
just started writing her actual family. I did. Okay, that's what I thought. Yeah, I wrote down Bob and Millie, Jim and Debbie, Ed. Yeah, you wrote down Ed, Mark, Jim and Debbie. It looked like Anne, which is your mom's name. That's my mom. Yeah? Yeah. Okay.
开始写她真正的家人了。我写了。好的，我当时就是这么想的。是的，我写下了鲍勃和米莉，吉姆和黛比，埃德。是的，你写下了埃德、马克、吉姆和黛比。看起来还有安，那是你妈妈的名字。那是我的妈妈。是吗？是的。好的。
I just thought it would be fun because maybe they would get to see their names on TV. No, I think that's fantastic. I would have done the same thing. I'm pretty sure my uncle Bob did write me an email because he noticed or someone noticed and told him. So that was like a fun little thing. I think it's also good that your family has somewhat
我只是觉得这会很有趣，因为也许他们能在电视上看到自己的名字。不，我觉得这太棒了。我也会做同样的事情。我很确定我叔叔鲍勃确实给我写了封邮件，因为他注意到了，或者有人注意到了并告诉了他。所以那是一件有趣的小事。我觉得你的家人有某种
like common names because like I would have done the same thing, but my list would have been like birdie. My aunt Thelma, like it'd be like, wait, this list looks a little Southern. Let's see next up, Dwight gets a Valentine's Day gift. There's a box on his desk. He gets the best gift ever. Yes, he gets a Dwight bobblehead, a bobblehead of himself. And we had a fan question.
像常见的名字也很好，因为我也会做同样的事情，但我的名单会像伯迪。我的阿姨塞尔玛，就像，等等，这份名单看起来有点南方风格。让我们看看接下来，德怀特收到了情人节礼物。他的桌上有一个盒子。他收到了有史以来最好的礼物。是的，他收到了一个德怀特摇头娃娃，他自己的摇头娃娃。我们有一个粉丝问题。
Actually, a lot of people asked, but Kelly Peck and Enza from Chicago both asked, how was the Dwight bobblehead made? So Phil Shea found a bobblehead maker on the internet, and he had rain pose for pictures in his Dwight outfit, and they took pictures of him from all directions. All angles. Yes. And sent them in. It took a couple of weeks, and they sent back a sample.
实际上，很多人都问了，但芝加哥的凯利·佩克和恩扎都问，德怀特摇头娃娃是怎么制作的？所以菲尔·谢在网上找到了一个摇头娃娃制作商，他让雷恩穿着他的德怀特服装摆姿势拍照，他们从各个方向拍了他的照片。所有角度。是的。并把它们寄了过去。花了几个星期，他们寄回了一个样品。
They were able to make notes, and then they sent the real thing and they just sent the one guy. I remember the real thing too was kind of fragile. Yeah. It was heavy. Heavy. Heavy. It's not like the ones you can buy now online.
他们能够做笔记，然后他们寄来了成品，他们只寄了一个。我记得成品也挺脆弱的。是的。它很重。重。重。不像你现在在网上买的那种。
Not made out of plastic. And if you want one of yourself, the guy's still making them. Oh, what's his name? Let's give him a shout out. It's bobblemaker.com. Bobblemaker.com made the original Dwight bobblehead. That's right. And it was originally called It's You Small.
不是塑料做的。如果你想要一个你自己的，那个人还在做。哦，他叫什么名字？让我们给他打个广告。是bobblemaker.com。Bobblemaker.com制作了最初的德怀特摇头娃娃。没错。它最初叫“It's You Small”。
It's You Small. I like that. It's You Small. But yeah, bobblemaker.com. That's where you can get a bobblehead made of yourself. And I went on there and they're really great. You can also get them made of your pets, your whole family. He'll also just sculpt your face and put it on a coffee mug, like coming out of a coffee
It's You Small。我喜欢那个。It's You Small。但是的，bobblemaker.com。那就是你可以制作自己摇头娃娃的地方。我上去看了，它们真的很棒。你也可以制作你宠物的、你全家人的。他甚至会雕刻你的脸，把它放在咖啡杯上，就像从咖啡
mug. That one I wasn't quite as attracted to. I'm going to just be honest. The coffee mug giving birth to your face? Yeah. But the bobbleheads are amazing. I would kind of like a bobblehead of our cat Oreo. I thought the same thing about Sunny.
杯里出来一样。那个我不太感兴趣。我老实说。咖啡杯生出你的脸？是的。但摇头娃娃太棒了。我有点想要一个我们家猫奥利奥的摇头娃娃。我对桑尼也有同样的想法。
Oh, we should get kitty cat bobbleheads. I want a kitty cat bobblehead. Okay, where are we? I had another question about the bobblehead from Dagmara K. Did anyone end up keeping Dwight's bobblehead? Well, I just assumed that Rain got to keep it. So I texted him and he said no. Who kept it? NBC. And they auctioned it off when the series ended. Oh,
哦，我们应该弄些小猫摇头娃娃。我想要一个猫咪摇头娃娃。好的，我们到哪了？我还有另一个关于达格玛拉·K提出的摇头娃娃的问题。有人最后留下了德怀特的摇头娃娃吗？嗯，我以为雷恩留下了。所以我发短信问他，他说没有。谁留下了？NBC。他们在剧集结束时把它拍卖了。哦，
that makes me a little sad. It makes me a little sad too. And it brought up a question for me. I remember NBC did this big auction of all our stuff. They auctioned off some of our clothes. Oh, there was a big auction. I think they auctioned off all the desks and furniture. A bunch of stuff from the desk, a bunch of furniture. But it made me wonder, with all this talk and speculation about a possible reboot, how do they get all the stuff back? How do they even recreate the set if they auctioned everything off?
这让我有点难过。我也觉得有点难过。这让我想到了一个问题。我记得NBC拍卖了我们所有的东西。他们拍卖了我们的一些衣服。哦，有一场大拍卖。我想他们拍卖了所有的桌子和家具。桌子上的一堆东西，一堆家具。但这让我好奇，随着所有关于可能重启的讨论和猜测，他们怎么把所有东西拿回来？如果他们把一切都拍卖了，他们怎么重建场景？
Well, I think that probably doesn't bode well for a reboot. I think people are like, nope. They'll have to get bobblemaker.com to make another bobblehead, I guess. I don't know. I actually have a Dwight and Angela bobblehead. And I bought one, and Rain signed it for me. So I have signed Rain bobblehead.
嗯，我想这可能对重启不是个好兆头。我想人们会说，不。他们得找bobblemaker.com再做一个摇头娃娃，我想。我不知道。我实际上有一个德怀特和安吉拉的摇头娃娃。我买了一个，雷恩为我签了名。所以我有一个雷恩签名的摇头娃娃。
After this episode, people started asking for Dwight bobbleheads. And so NBC made a run of bobbleheads. They found a way to make them mass produce them. Yes. And they sold out immediately. All right. So next up in the episode, Michael is walking the streets of New York.
在这一集之后，人们开始要求德怀特摇头娃娃。所以NBC制作了一批摇头娃娃。他们找到了大规模生产它们的方法。是的。它们立刻就卖光了。好的。那么接下来在这一集中，迈克尔走在纽约的街头。
Oh, he's so happy. Oh, he's he walks by his favorite local New York pizza joint, Sbarro. You can only find it in New York. It's such a great joke because you guys know Sbarro is a huge chain. You can get it outside of New York City. However, this made me curious about Sbarro. So guess what I found out. What you find out, lady.
哦，他太开心了。哦，他走过他最喜欢的当地纽约披萨店，Sbarro。你只能在纽约找到它。这是一个很棒的笑话，因为你们知道Sbarro是一个巨大的连锁店。你在纽约市以外也能买到。然而，这让我对Sbarro感到好奇。所以猜猜我发现了什么。你发现了什么，女士。
Let me tell you, Sbarro began in 1956 when Carmela and Gennaro Sbarro opened an Italian grocery store in Brooklyn that also happened to sell food. Okay. So they had a little deli. They had a little market. Yes. And one of the things that they sold was pizza by the slice. Mama Sbarro, as she was known, had this pizza by the slice and it became super popular with construction workers, shift workers who needed to grab something in one hand and eat on the go. They became so popular that they ended up opening a second location that was only about pizza. Okay. Pizza only. We are not sponsored by Spar- We are not.
让我告诉你，Sbarro始于1956年，当时卡梅拉和詹纳罗·斯巴罗在布鲁克林开了一家意大利杂货店，碰巧也卖食物。好的。所以他们有一个小熟食店。他们有一个小市场。是的。他们卖的东西之一就是切片披萨。斯巴罗妈妈，正如她所知，有这种切片披萨，它在建筑工人和轮班工人中变得非常受欢迎，他们需要一只手抓着东西，在路上吃。他们变得如此受欢迎，以至于他们最终开了第二家只卖披萨的店。好的。只卖披萨。我们没有被Sbar-赞助。我们没有。
Spar-Boro, probably cause I can't say it. Spar-Boro? Sabaro. Sabaro, not Spar-Boro. Not Spar-Boro. That's a different restaurant. Sabaro, Sabaro. Sabaro.
Sbar-Boro，可能是因为我不会说。Sbar-Boro？Sabaro。Sabaro，不是Sbar-Boro。不是Sbar-Boro。那是另一家餐厅。Sabaro，Sabaro。Sabaro。
And so since then though, Sabaro has expanded into 630 eateries across 28 countries. I'm applauding you, Sbarboro. Also, on their website, it says, quote, you're welcome, world. Well, well, not only pizza slices, but pizza slices with sass. I like it. That's some Sbarro sass. That's some Sbarro sass. I like it. That's some Sbarro sass. That's some Sbarro sass. But I thought it was interesting because the joke of our episode is kind of that Michael doesn't get what a local pizza
从那时起，Sabaro已经扩展到28个国家的630家餐馆。我为你鼓掌，Sbarboro。此外，在他们的网站上，它写着，引用，“不客气，世界。”嗯，嗯，不仅是披萨片，而且是带有态度的披萨片。我喜欢它。那是一些Sbarro的态度。那是一些Sbarro的态度。我喜欢它。那是一些Sbarro的态度。那是一些Sbarro的态度。但我认为这很有趣，因为我们这一集的笑话有点像迈克尔不明白什么是当地披萨
joint is, but it did actually start as a local pizza joint. It did start local. It did start local. Just not in Times Square. So there you go. So next we go back to the office and Jim and Kelly are in the kitchen. I love this scene so much. John Krasinski, your acting in this scene is delicious. It's delicious. Mindy's acting is delicious. I was like, she's so funny in it. She's full on Mindy. Yeah, it's full Mindy. This is full Mindy. I want you to know when I was listening to the DVD commentary, I almost like spit out like the water I was drinking because Greg and Mike both go, oh, I mean, Mindy just took
店，但它确实是从一家当地披萨店开始的。它确实是从当地开始的。它确实是从当地开始的。只是不在时代广场。所以就是这样。所以接下来我们回到办公室，吉姆和凯利在厨房里。我太喜欢这一幕了。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，你在这一幕中的表演太美味了。太美味了。敏迪的表演太美味了。我当时想，她在里面太搞笑了。她完全是敏迪。是的，这是完全的敏迪。这是完全的敏迪。我想让你知道，当我听DVD评论时，我差点把喝的水喷出来，因为格雷格和迈克都说，哦，我是说，敏迪只是接管了。
over. Like, there's no more Kelly. It's just Mindy. This was a whole thing. Yeah, what they don't know is that it happened last episode. Okay. Well, I felt very validated that we didn't even know that like they totally talk about it in the commentary.
就像，没有凯利了。只有敏迪。这整件事。是的，他们不知道的是，这发生在上集。好的。嗯，我觉得很欣慰，我们甚至不知道他们在评论中完全谈到了这一点。
That's amazing. Well, basically, she tells Jim that her and Ryan hooked up last night. Yes. And Mindy says in the DVD commentary, she goes, Mike, I really feel like this scene is just like a transcription of a conversation you and I actually had about a guy. Which cracked me up. Well, it leads to the very famous Ryan Talkinghead. I hooked up with her on February 13th. I know, it was like so perfect.
太神奇了。嗯，基本上，她告诉吉姆她和瑞恩昨晚在一起了。是的。敏迪在DVD评论中说，她说，迈克，我真的觉得这一幕就像是你和我实际上关于一个男人进行的对话的转录。这让我大笑。嗯，它引出了非常有名的瑞恩采访镜头。我在2月13日和她在一起了。我知道，这太完美了。
All right, so then we head back to New York City again, and now we're gonna see Michael in Times Square. You know, a lot of people, he tells you, they get to New York and they go to really touristy places, like the Empire State Building, but he likes to go to Times Square. Yeah, he likes to go to the most tourist spot in New York. Which I love.
好的，所以我们再次回到纽约市，现在我们要看迈克尔在时代广场。你知道，很多人，他告诉你，他们到了纽约，去了非常旅游的地方，比如帝国大厦，但他喜欢去时代广场。是的，他喜欢去纽约最旅游的地方。我喜欢这一点。
And then at five minutes, 26 seconds, Michael is giving us a tour of Rockefeller Center. Yes. Where he says, founded of course, by Theodore Rockefeller. And he also says that the Rangers sometimes practice there. OK, I did a deep dive. The Rangers don't practice there. The Rangers don't practice there,
然后在5分26秒，迈克尔正在带我们参观洛克菲勒中心。是的。他说，当然是由西奥多·洛克菲勒创立的。他还说游骑兵队有时在那里练习。好的，我深入研究了一下。游骑兵队不在那里练习。游骑兵队不在那里练习，
but they do sometimes practice at this rink in Central Park. Like once a year, there's a rink there. I know this because I have a huge hockey. Yeah, I'm a hockey mom. Your husband plays hockey. your son plays hockey, you're a hockey mom. Yes, we've been in New York when the Rangers have practiced on this rink in Central Park, and it's super cool.
但他们有时在中央公园的这个溜冰场练习。就像一年一次，那里有一个溜冰场。我知道这一点，因为我有一个巨大的曲棍球。是的，我是个曲棍球妈妈。你丈夫打曲棍球。你儿子打曲棍球，你是曲棍球妈妈。是的，我们在纽约时，游骑兵队在中央公园的这个溜冰场练习过，这太酷了。
It's a thing they do for the fans. But never at Rockefeller Center. Also, there is no one named Theodore Rockefeller. I did a deep dive on the Rockefeller family, and I could not find anyone named Theodore. Okay, I know 30 Rock really well because I worked there. Oh, that's right. I was an intern on the Conan O'Brien show.
这是他们为粉丝做的一件事。但从不在洛克菲勒中心。此外，没有叫西奥多·洛克菲勒的人。我深入研究了洛克菲勒家族，我找不到任何叫西奥多的人。好的，我非常了解《我为喜剧狂》，因为我在那里工作过。哦，没错。我是柯南·奥布莱恩节目的实习生。
And so we're like a bunch of office people. Mindy, Ellie, John. But not at the same time. Not at the same time. I'm much older than those guys. I was there the very first year of Conan when they thought they were going to get canceled, week to week. Oh my gosh. What do you do when you're an intern on that? What is that? What does that mean?
所以我们就像一群办公室的人。敏迪、艾莉、约翰。但不是同时。不是同时。我比那些家伙大得多。我在柯南的第一年就在那里，当时他们以为会被取消，每周都在担心。天哪。当你做实习生时你做什么？那是什么？那意味着什么？
Well, there was different types of internships. There was a writer's intern. So when I got the internship, they already had the writer's intern. So I became a general intern. So I just basically got everyone their coffee. I didn't know New York City, so I kept getting lost. I was probably the worst coffee run person ever. Did you get to meet Conan or interact with him as an intern? I didn't. And I mean, he would walk past and he was always nice. He would kind of give a nod or away, but he was busy, you know? And I knew not to bug him. Like I had enough like awareness that I wasn't going to be like, Hey, Conan, I'm the new intern, what you doing?
嗯，有不同类型的实习。有编剧实习生。所以当我得到实习机会时，他们已经有了编剧实习生。所以我成了普通实习生。所以我基本上就是给每个人买咖啡。我不了解纽约市，所以我一直迷路。我可能是史上最差的咖啡跑腿人。你作为实习生见到柯南或与他互动了吗？我没有。我的意思是，他会走过去，他总是很友善。他会点头或挥手，但他很忙，你知道吗？我知道不要打扰他。就像我有足够的意识，我不会像，嘿，柯南，我是新实习生，你在做什么？
The really cool thing about Conan Studio is it was one floor away from where they did Saturday Night Live. So could you- You could do a back door- Like watch SNL ever? I actually, one of the people that worked on Conan knew that I was pretty strapped for cash
柯南工作室真正酷的地方在于，它离他们做《周六夜现场》的地方只有一层楼。所以你能——你可以走后门——就像看过SNL吗？实际上，在柯南工作的人中，有一个人知道我手头很紧，
and she got me a weekend job on Saturday Night Live as an extra. So there's a whole season of SNL that I'm an extra and I'm in a bunch of skits. What? Yes. There's a great scene with Chris Farley and I'm sitting in front of him, and everyone was so nice. Yeah, because all that stuff is happening in that same building. That's what's so crazy about that area.
她给我找了一份《周六夜现场》的周末工作，做临时演员。所以有一整季的SNL我都是临时演员，我在一堆短剧中。什么？是的。有一个和克里斯·法利很棒的场景，我坐在他前面，每个人都太好了。是的，因为所有这些事情都发生在同一栋楼里。这就是那个区域如此疯狂的地方。
And NBC News is happening in the Today Show, That's what's so crazy about that area. And like NBC News is happening and the Today show, it's all right there. Can I tell you one of the coolest moments? Is right outside the stage doors where we recorded, I'm standing in this hallway alone. There's no one in the hallway. The elevator doors open and Robert Redford walked out. Wow.
NBC新闻正在发生，还有《今日秀》，这就是那个区域如此疯狂的地方。NBC新闻正在发生，还有《今日秀》，都在那里。我能告诉你最酷的时刻之一吗？就在我们录制的舞台门外，我独自站在这个走廊里。走廊里没有人。电梯门开了，罗伯特·雷德福走了出来。哇。
And he was with like an NBC, you know, someone in a suit and they were walking down the hall and they just walked past me and I was just like, just watched Robert Redford walk right by. Wow. I'm just like a young kid from middle of nowhere, Texas. It was just like a really cool, surreal moment. And there were many of those in my time there. That is pretty awesome.
他和NBC的人在一起，你知道，穿着西装的人，他们走在走廊上，他们只是从我身边走过，我当时就像，只是看着罗伯特·雷德福走过去。哇。我只是一个来自德克萨斯州偏僻地方的年轻人。那只是一个非常酷、超现实的时刻。我在那里的时间里有很多这样的时刻。那真是太棒了。
So we got a lot of fan questions about this Tina Fey, Conan O'Brien business. The first one is from Sarah Marshall, 44. Did production hire the woman to play the fake Tina Fey or was she just a random person? No, we hired her. She is an actress named Miriam Tolan. She's been in a ton of stuff,
所以我们收到了很多关于蒂娜·菲、柯南·奥布莱恩这件事的粉丝问题。第一个来自莎拉·马歇尔，44。制作组是雇佣了这个女人来扮演假蒂娜·菲，还是她只是个随机的人？不，我们雇佣了她。她是一位名叫米里亚姆·托兰的女演员。她演过很多东西，
including ironically an episode of 30 Rock, season two, episode 14. She has a really funny scene with Jason Satekis around 12 minutes. She plays a woman at a check-in counter at an airline. It's very funny. I went back and watched the whole episode. Oh, I want to see it. It's really good.
讽刺的是，包括一集《我为喜剧狂》，第二季第14集。她在12分钟左右和杰森·苏戴奇斯有一个非常有趣的场景。她扮演航空公司值机柜台的一名妇女。非常有趣。我回去看了整集。哦，我想看。真的很好。
And then we had another fan question from Livy Fitzgerald. Please explain the Conan cameo. Well, you know, Greg and Conan were very good friends. They went to college together. They were roommates. I think some of their very early writing jobs on SNL and Simpsons, they were like, they lived together. They're friends.
然后我们有另一个来自利维·菲茨杰拉德的粉丝问题。请解释一下柯南的客串。嗯，你知道，格雷格和柯南是非常好的朋友。他们一起上大学。他们是室友。我想他们在SNL和辛普森一家的一些非常早期的写作工作中，他们住在一起。他们是朋友。
They're really good friends. And so it definitely makes sense that Greg, you know, would want to reach out to Conan if he was right there. There is quite a bit about it in the DVD commentary, but one of the things that really stuck with me that I loved is that Greg said it took Conan 15 takes to time that out. Like he said, literally it took about 15 tries.
他们真的是好朋友。所以格雷格如果他在那里，想要联系柯南，这绝对说得通。DVD评论中有很多关于它的内容，但我喜欢并一直记在心里的一件事是，格雷格说柯南花了15次拍摄才把时间掌握好。就像他说，字面上花了大约15次尝试。
And he said, you think Steve gets a big crowd? Imagine Conan standing in front of the building where they taped Conan. He said the crowds were crazy. so they were trying to get that. And he's really tall. He's incredibly tall. And has red hair. He's very, very distinguishable.
他说，你以为史蒂夫吸引了很多人？想象一下柯南站在他们录制柯南的楼前。他说人群太疯狂了。所以他们试图得到那个。而且他真的很高。他高得不可思议。还有红头发。他非常、非常显眼。
Hard to blend. Hard to blend. Mike sure said that he wrote the scene with fake Tina Fey as a shout out to her, a little nod to their time together on Saturday Night Live, because he said tourists were constantly mistaking other women with brown hair and glasses for Tina Fey. It was almost like a joke. They would watch other women get tapped on the shoulder,
很难融入。很难融入。迈克·舒尔说他写那个假蒂娜·菲的场景是为了向她致敬，对他俩在《周六夜现场》共事时光的一点点头，因为他说游客经常把其他棕色头发和戴眼镜的女人误认为是蒂娜·菲。这几乎像个笑话。他们会看着其他女人被拍肩膀，
and it was never Tina Fey. And he said that many times him and Tina would take a coffee break in between writing and walk outside, and no one would stop her. No one would stop the real Tina outside and no one would stop her. No one would stop the real Tina Fey. No one would stop the real Tina Fey, but they would mistake all these other women.
但那从来不是蒂娜·菲。他说很多次他和蒂娜会在写作间隙休息喝咖啡，走出去，没有人会拦住她。没有人会拦住外面的真蒂娜，没有人会拦住她。没有人会拦住真正的蒂娜·菲。没有人会拦住真正的蒂娜·菲，但他们会把所有这些其他女人认错。
And so he said that scene was kind of his little nod to Tina. Oh my gosh, I love that. I did too. I love that. All right, so next we go back into the office and more flowers arrive for Phyllis. Oh, gosh.
所以他说那一幕算是他对蒂娜的一点点头。天哪，我喜欢那个。我也喜欢。好的，所以接下来我们回到办公室，更多的花送给了菲利斯。哦，天哪。
From Bob Vance. I mean, Bob Vance. Not for Pam. They're for Phyllis. Pam is getting annoyed. And you know who else is taking it hard? Meredith. Meredith.
来自鲍勃·万斯。我是说，鲍勃·万斯。不是给帕姆的。是给菲利斯的。帕姆感到很烦。你知道还有谁很难受吗？梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思。
She's taking it real hard. She's looking real sour. Yeah. Well, then we have this awesome covert scene between Dwight and Angela at the copier. Yes. He says, thank you for the gift. And then she says, I haven't gotten one yet. I haven't gotten anything. Now, this has nothing to do with the scene, but I have to bring it up right now because this is the first moment you really get a full shot of me, right on camera. Yeah.
她真的很难受。她看起来真的很酸。是的。嗯，然后我们在复印机旁有这个很棒的秘密场景，德怀特和安吉拉。是的。他说，谢谢你的礼物。然后她说，我还没收到呢。我什么都没收到。现在，这和场景无关，但我现在必须提出来，因为这是你第一次真正完全出现在镜头里，对吧？是的。我看起来晒黑了吗，珍娜？我看起来有点晒黑了吗？是的，既然你提到了。哦，我晒得很黑，因为在我的日记里，你们这些家伙，我写道，我们是在金球奖期间拍摄的，当时我做了那个神秘喷雾美黑。哦，没错。当我们去金球奖时，
Do I look tan, Jenna? Do I look a little tan? Yes, now that you mentioned it. Oh, I am very tan because in my journal, you guys, I wrote, we shot this during the Golden Globes when I got that Mystic Spray Tan. Oh, that's right. When we went to the Golden Globes,
当史蒂夫赢了时，你做了一个非常黑的喷雾美黑。是橙色的。伙计们，我看了这一集和下一集。我像橙子一样持续了两个星期。天哪。我的意思是，我晒得太黑了。太荒谬了。他们试图让我的脸看起来更亮。
when Steve won, you got a spray tan that was real dark. It was orange. Guys, I watched this episode and the next one. I am like orange for two weeks. Oh my gosh. I mean, I am so tan. It's ridiculous. And they tried to like make my face look lighter.
就像我在日记里写的，他们试图淡化我的美黑。但发生的事情是我看起来很奇怪。我觉得你在这一集中看起来不错。嗯，我做了神秘美黑，喷雾美黑。但无论如何，当我看到那一幕时，我只能看到我非常、非常黑的前额。在雷恩旁边，我看起来黑得疯狂，因为他太白了。但是的，我已经给了德怀特，他说这是有史以来最好的礼物。是的。
Like I wrote about it in my journal that they tried to tone down my tan. But what happened was I just look weird. I thought you looked good in this episode. Well, I have a mystic tan, a spray tan. But anyway, when I watched that scene, all I could see was my very, very tan forehead. And next to Rain, I look crazy tan, because he's so white. But yes, I have given Dwight, he says the best gift ever. Yeah.
然后他承诺他有一个给我的，我对此非常高兴。然后他显然意识到，哦不，现在我必须兑现了。没错，没错。他说，你今天结束前会收到东西的。他需要给自己一些时间。是的。在今天结束前收到东西。他需要给自己一些时间。是的。收到东西。好的。所以接下来我们有吉姆在打电话的场景。
And then he promises that he has one for me, which I'm very happy about. And then he clearly realizes, oh no, now I have to deliver. Exactly, exactly. He says, you'll get something by the end of today. He needs to give himself some time. Yeah. To get something by the end of today. He needs to give himself some time. Yeah. To get something. All right. So then we have the scene where Jim is on the phone.
他正在和他的扑克牌友制定计划。约翰·卡拉辛斯基的假电话演得太棒了。你们这些家伙，假电话不容易。不，电话那头没有人。我完全相信他在和某人说话，他的笑声看起来很自然。是的。我当时想，约翰，为假电话技巧鼓掌。很棒的假电话。
He's making plans with his poker buddies. John Krasinski does such great fake phone. You guys, fake phone is not easy. No, there's no one on the other end of that call. I fully believed he's talking to someone and his laugh seems so organic. Yeah. I'm like, John, applause for fake phone skills. Great fake phone.
真的，真的很好。这也是他们关系中的某个时间点，如果你愿意的话，吉姆，我的意思是，你定了一个婚礼日期。是的。帕姆谈论的真的只是像计划婚礼。而吉姆真的开始定婚礼日期了。就像帕姆谈论的真的只是像计划婚礼。而吉姆真的开始退缩了。然后你看到帕姆感受到了那种缺席。
Really, really good. And this is also sort of the time in their relationship, if you will, where Jim, I mean, you have a wedding date set. Yeah. It's like all that Pam is talking about really is like planning the wedding. And Jim really starts wedding date set. It's like all that Pam is talking about really is like planning the wedding. And Jim really starts to pull away. And then you see Pam feeling that absence.
嗯，记住在上集，他们因为帕姆决定不追求她的平面设计实习而大吵了一架。所以我认为吉姆有点觉得，我不知道我在这里该做什么。我不知道我还能适应哪里。是的，而且她要结婚了。是的。
Well, and remember in the last episode, they got in a full fight about Pam's decision to not pursue her graphic design internship. And so I think Jim kind of feels like, I don't know what I'm supposed to do here. I don't know where I fit in anymore. Yeah, and she's getting married. Yeah.
然后一个巨大的泰迪熊到了。它是由两个穿着万斯制冷服装的人送来的。他们由我们的编剧团队吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格扮演。但你只看到了吉恩。李被剪掉了。李被剪掉了。
Then a giant teddy bear arrives. And it's being delivered by two guys, advanced refrigeration outfits. They were played by our writing team of Jean Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg. But you only see Gene. Lee got cut out. Lee got cut out.
在删减片段里。是的，他们打了一架。是的，这有点荒谬。但吉恩是说“菲利斯·拉平？”的人。所以如果你想知道哪个是吉恩，哪个是李，吉恩在这一集里。他们后来还会回来。他们会再次出现，你实际上会看到李。
It's in the deleted scene. Yeah, they get in a fistfight. Yeah, it's kind of ridiculous. But Gene is the person who says, Phyllis Lapin? So if you're wondering which one is Gene and which one is Lee, Gene is in this episode. And they come back later. They're going to recur, and you'll actually get to see Lee.
吉恩和布莱恩饰演的凯文之间有一个非常有趣的交流，凯文说，那东西和我一样大。吉恩说，不，它不是。不，它不是。凯文说，闭嘴。所以现在迈克尔终于到了他的会议。他已经逛完了纽约的街道
There's a very funny little sort of exchange between Jean and Brian as Kevin where Kevin's like, that thing's as big as me. And Jean's like, no, it's not. No, it's not. Kevin's like, zip it. So now Michael has finally made it to his meeting. He's done wandering the streets of New York
他要在会议室见其他分公司经理。我只想提一下，我们之前说过，这部分不是在纽约拍摄的。这是在一些舞台上拍摄的。就在我们每天在加利福尼亚拍摄的地方。是的。看看窗外。
and he's gonna meet with the other branch managers in a conference room. And I just want to mention, we said this earlier, this part of it was not shot in New York. This was shot on some stages. Right there where we film every day in California. Yes. Look out the window.
他们做得太棒了。背景，看起来真的像他们在纽约的一栋高楼里。欺骗性太好了。我们的场景设计团队太棒了。是的，但实际上他们是在加利福尼亚范奈斯的一个仓库场景里。在加利福尼亚范奈斯。是的，有点神奇。但让我们见见其他经理。
They did such a good job. The backdrop, it really looks like they're up high in a building in New York. The trickery is so good. Our set design team was phenomenal. Yeah, but really they are on ground level in a warehouse in a set. In Van Nuys, California. Yeah, kind of amazing. But let's meet the other managers.
是的，我有一张卡片。好的，把你的卡片给我，女士。这是卡片。好的，把你的卡片给我，女士。这是我的卡片。所以其他经理是丹·戈尔，他管理布法罗，由丹·科尔扮演；乔什·波特，他管理斯坦福分公司；克雷格，迈克尔叫他克雷格斯，由克雷格·安东扮演，管理奥尔巴尼。是的。
Yes, I have a card. All right, give me your card, lady. Here's a card. All right, give me your card, lady. Here's my card. So the other managers are Dan Gore, who manages Buffalo, played by Dan Cole, Josh Porter, he manages Stanford branch, Craig, Michael calls him Craigers, played by Craig Anton, manages Albany. Yes.
所以这里有一个关于丹·戈尔角色的小花絮。好的。在DVD评论中，迈克·舒尔说，会议室里那个安静的家伙，他以他的好朋友丹·戈尔，编剧丹·戈尔的名字命名。哦，是的。丹·戈尔，我的意思是，他创作了《神烦警探》。他是一位了不起的编剧。是的。
So here's a little tidbit about the Dan Gore character. Okay. In the DVD commentary, Mike sure says, the quiet guy in the conference room, he named after his good friend, Dan Gore, the writer Dan Gore. Oh yeah. Dan Gore, who I mean, he created Brooklyn Nine-Nine. He's a phenomenal writer. Yeah.
他是迈克的朋友，敏迪插话说迈克喜欢那样做。他喜欢把朋友的名字放进东西里。他是柯南的编剧。他写过《公园与游憩》，现在，当然，他是《神烦警探》的剧集主管。所以丹·戈尔在这一集中得到了一个很好的小致敬。是的。所以我们正在见所有的分公司负责人，而克雷格斯是个白痴。他是对的。他被奥尔巴尼所有的脱衣舞俱乐部赶出来了。
And he was a friend of Mike's and Mindy sort of chimed in that Mike loved to do that. He loved to put his friends names in things. He was a Conan writer. He wrote on Parks and Rec, and now, of course, he's the showrunner of Brooklyn Nine-Nine. So Dan Gore got a nice little shout out in this episode. Yes. So we are meeting all the branch heads, and Craigers is an idiot. He's right. He's gotten kicked out of all the strip clubs in Albany.
对此非常自豪。我们发现了。然后他开始侮辱简。是的。是的，他说。他叫她那个B开头的词。他确实说了，迈克尔为她辩护。他说，哦，得了吧，得了吧。他首先站出来为她说，那是我的女朋友，伙计。
Very proud of that. We find out. And then he starts insulting Jan. Yeah. Yeah, he says. He calls her the B word. He does, and Michael comes to her defense. He says, oh, come on now, come on now. And he stands up for her first by saying, that's my girlfriend, boy.
然后他退缩了，说，我是说，我们在一起了。然后乔什·波特说，你和简在一起了？现在他进去了。他泄露了秘密。该死，迈克尔。迈克尔。他才在那里待了五分钟。是的，他和一个房间里的人
And then he backpedals and says, I mean, we hooked up. And then Josh Porter's like, you hooked up with Jan? And now he's in it. He spilled the beans. Dang it, Michael. Michael. He's only been there like five minutes. Yeah, he's been in a room with these people
待了五分钟，他已经告诉所有人他和简在一起了。和他们的老板。是的。哦，迈克尔。然后房间里就像蟋蟀叫一样。好的，好吧，也许我们应该休息一下。是的，带着那个消息。关于那个消息，迈克尔刚刚泄露了秘密
for five minutes and he's already told everyone that he's hooked up with Jan. With their boss. Yeah. Oh, Michael. And then it's like crickets in the room. All right, well, maybe we should take a break. Yeah, with that news. On that news, Michael has just spilled the beans
我们马上回来。我们会回来的。因为我最喜欢的场景之一正在办公室发生。是的。我们需要谈谈它。这是好东西。很好。通过Fizz忠诚度计划，
and we'll be right back. We'll be back. Because one of my favorite scenes is happening back at the office. Yeah. We need to talk about it. It's good stuff. It's good. With the Fizz loyalty program,
你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。你知道，为了发短信之类的。如果你没有通过你的移动套餐获得额外数据和美元折扣等奖励，你就不是Fizz的用户。今天就切换吧。条件适用。详情请见fizz.ca。好的，我们回来了。
you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Okay, so we're back.
伙计们，我必须谈谈德怀特和帕姆在休息室的这一幕。我太喜欢它了，珍娜。我倒回去看了好几次。天哪，你是怎么忍住不笑的？当他说“像火腿一样？”时你的反应，你说，不，不完全像火腿。珍娜太搞笑了。我不知道你是怎么保持严肃表情的。
You guys, I have to talk about this scene between Dwight and Pam in the break room. I loved it so much, Jenna. I rewound and watched it a few times. Oh gosh, how did you get through it without laughing? Your reaction when he says, like a ham? And you're like, no, not exactly like a ham. Jenna is so funny. I don't even know how you kept straight face though.
我的意图是，就像我在和五六岁的孩子说话，我不能让他们看到我对他们说的话的真实感受。是的，完全正确。我们有一个来自苏西·杨22的粉丝问题。她想知道“像火腿一样”是写好的还是即兴的。是即兴的。他即兴发挥了很多吗？是的。在那一天，我们并没有真正为这一幕写结局。好的。我们让他进来寻求建议，他们想要一个结尾，这在场景中经常发生，编剧们随后会过来给我们提供一系列选择。
My intention in that was like I was talking to like a ham. Jenna is so funny. I don't even know how you kept straight face though. My intention in that was like I was talking to like a five or a six year old and I couldn't let them see my real feelings about the things they were saying. Yeah, exactly. We had a fan question from Suzy Young 22. She wanted to know if like a ham was scripted or improvised. It was improvised. Did he improvise a bunch? Yeah. So on the day, we didn't really have an ending to this scene. Okay. We had him coming in and asking for advice and they wanted a button and this would often happen in scenes and the writers would then come over and give us a list of options.
我当时那样做是因为我感觉就像在跟一个火腿说话。珍娜太搞笑了。我真不知道你是怎么忍住不笑场的。我当时那样做是因为我感觉就像在跟一个五六岁的孩子说话，我不能让他们看出我对他们所说的话的真实感受。没错，就是这样。我们收到了来自Suzy Young 22的一位粉丝提问。她想知道“像个火腿”那段是写好的剧本还是即兴发挥的。那是即兴发挥的。他即兴发挥了很多吗？是的。所以在那天，我们其实并没有给这场戏设计结尾。好吧。我们安排他进来寻求建议，他们想要一个点睛之笔，这种情况在拍摄中经常发生，编剧们就会过来给我们提供一系列选项。
Like suggestions. Yeah. So Like a Ham was improvised, but then there were and give us a list of options. Like suggestions. Yeah. So like a ham was improvised, but then there were all these other options that were written on a piece of paper. And so we shot all of these things that he said, like, like a this, like a that, like this, like that. It was so hard not to laugh.
就像建议一样。是的。所以“像火腿一样”是即兴发挥的，但当时还有很多写在纸上的选项。所以我们拍摄了他说的所有东西，比如，像这个，像那个，像这样，像那样。忍住不笑真的太难了。
I did laugh at like a ham because it wasn't on the piece of paper. So I was not expecting it. No, no. So that my response is definitely like take four or five because I remember everyone just lost it when he said it. And then they were like, okay, wait, that's good. That's good. That's the one we want. And so then they were like, pull it together and do it again. Do it again. Okay, I have a question for you. When he says shut up, I know exactly what to do. Was that improvised? That I don't remember.
我确实因为“像火腿一样”笑了，因为它不在纸上。所以我完全没预料到。不，不。所以我的反应绝对是第四或第五次拍摄的，因为我记得当他说出那句话时，每个人都笑疯了。然后他们说，好吧，等等，那个好。那个好。那就是我们要的那个。然后他们说，振作起来，再来一次。再来一次。好吧，我有个问题要问你。当他说“闭嘴”时，我知道该怎么做。那是即兴发挥的吗？那个我不记得了。
I don't remember because I do think that that final look to camera was, that was some direction I was given, which is like, I know the cameras out there. Yeah. And your look to camera is like, can this day get any worse? It's so weird. I'm not getting any gifts. No. Jim has barely acknowledged me and Dwight just asked for my help and then told me to shut up.
我不记得了，因为我觉得最后看向镜头的那个镜头，那是导演给我的指示，就像是，我知道摄像机在那儿。是的。你看向镜头的表情就像是，这一天还能再糟糕点吗？太奇怪了。我没收到任何礼物。不。吉姆几乎没理我，而德怀特刚向我寻求帮助，然后叫我闭嘴。
I also love when rain, how rain responds to me saying like, she's a little like tightly wound. Oh gosh. Yeah, he like chose to be like turned on by it. So gross. Kind of creepy. Did you notice how many times we were in scenes in the break room in the kitchen?
我也很喜欢雷恩，雷恩对我说的“她有点神经紧绷”的反应。天哪。是的，他选择被这种特质吸引。太恶心了。有点毛骨悚然。你注意到我们在休息室和厨房的场景里出现了多少次吗？
Like in this episode, we're in quite a few, I think we have like three break room scenes, two kitchen scenes. Yeah. So it's interesting. And I don't know if that's cause they were constantly trying to keep Jim and Pam apart, or there were these secret conversations about relationships.
比如在这一集中，我们有好几次，我想我们大概有三次休息室场景，两次厨房场景。是的。所以这很有趣。我不知道这是因为他们一直在试图让吉姆和帕姆分开，还是因为有关于关系的秘密谈话。
But I feel like this was a very interesting episode for that reason, because a lot of the scenes don't actually happen in the bullpen. Yeah, they're not at our desks this time. Mm-mm. Yeah. So Jim is in the break room with Kelly, and he's kind of trying to give her advice.
但我感觉这一集因为这个原因非常有趣，因为很多场景实际上并没有发生在办公区。是的，这次他们不在我们的办公桌旁。嗯嗯。是的。所以吉姆和凯利在休息室里，他正试图给她建议。
He's really just trying to eat his bag of chips. Yeah. He tells her to take it slow, and then Ryan walks in. And she asks him out in front of Jim and John's, the way John played this moment, like he's like, not in front of me. Oh, he's like, oh no, not while I'm here. No, please. Oh, so good.
他其实只是想吃他的薯片。是的。他告诉她慢慢来，然后瑞恩走了进来。她在吉姆面前约他出去，约翰演绎这一刻的方式，就像是，别在我面前。哦，他就像是，哦不，别在我在这儿的时候。不，拜托。哦，太棒了。
But Ryan shoots her down. He says, I can't, I have plans with friends and I can't. It's so cringy. And she's like, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's not a problem. Yeah. Oh, and Jim is just sitting there. Like, get me out of here.
但瑞恩拒绝了她。他说，我不行，我和朋友有约，我不能去。太尴尬了。她就像是，哦，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。没问题。是的。哦，吉姆就坐在那儿。就像是，让我离开这儿吧。
Back in the bullpen, more gifts for Phyllis. Meredith is drinking heavily. She's had it. She's full on mixing up a cocktail and that super gulp. I have been to family reunions where I have one or two aunts that walk around with a giant 7-Eleven super gulp and I have been to family reunions where I have one or two aunts that walk around with a giant 7-Eleven Super gulp and I'm always like, what's in there? What's in there?
回到办公区，给菲利斯的礼物更多了。梅雷迪斯喝得烂醉。她受够了。她正在那个超大杯里调鸡尾酒。我去过家庭聚会，那里有一两个阿姨拿着巨大的7-Eleven超大杯走来走去，我去过家庭聚会，那里有一两个阿姨拿着巨大的7-Eleven超大杯走来走去，我总是想，那里面是什么？那里面是什么？
Why are you nursing on that 7-Eleven Super gulp all day? Well, I used to do an opposite thing in college. So I was not a big drinker, but I wanted to go to the parties and not be judged. So you'd bring a Super gulp full of like soda? I would bring a red solo cup full. Your own solo cup to the party? I had my own red solo cup. And then I would put something non-alcoholic in it.
你为什么整天抱着那个7-Eleven超大杯喝？嗯，我在大学时做过相反的事情。我不是个大酒鬼，但我又想去参加派对，不想被评判。所以你会带一个装满苏打水的超大杯？我会带一个装满饮料的红色塑料杯。你自己带塑料杯去派对？我有我自己的红色塑料杯。然后我会往里面倒非酒精饮料。
And you'd be like, I'm good, I've got my drink. Yeah, I got it. I'm fine. I'm good. I don't need to get drunk on whatever you're handing out. Weird frat boy party. Oh my gosh. Have solo cup, weird frat boy party. Oh my gosh. Have solo cup, we'll travel.
然后你会说，我很好，我有我的饮料。是的，我有。我没事。我很好。我不需要喝你们分发的任何东西。奇怪的兄弟会派对。天哪。有塑料杯，就能去参加奇怪的兄弟会派对。天哪。有塑料杯，就能去参加奇怪的兄弟会派对。
Yeah, exactly. So I did like an opposite thing. A reverse. Yeah. A reverse Meredith. Should we go back to New York and meet our CFO David Wallace? Yeah, cause it's about to really go south.
是的，完全正确。所以我做了一件相反的事情。反向操作。是的。反向梅雷迪斯。我们要回纽约去见我们的首席财务官大卫·华莱士吗？是的，因为事情真的要变糟了。
And also, I mean, oh God. Yeah. How funny is faces of Scranton I don't want to jump ahead but that is some funny shiitake. Yeah it's time for the presentations. Josh Porter gives a nice normal presentation. Yes yes and you know in the DVD commentary Mike Schur said it was really important to him that you saw a range of competence in the that you saw a range of competence in the branch managers. A range of competence.
还有，我是说，天哪。是的。斯克兰顿的面孔有多好笑？我不想跳过，但那真是些有趣的玩意儿。是的，是时候进行演示了。乔什·波特做了一个不错的正常演示。是的，是的，你知道在DVD评论中，迈克·舒尔说对他来说，看到分公司经理们的能力范围非常重要。能力范围。
I like that phrase. Yes. I'm paraphrasing. I don't know that he said that exactly. But like Josh Porter is on it. He's got his presentation. He's got it down. And then you have, you know, Michael's kind of somewhere in the middle.
我喜欢这个短语。是的。我是在转述。我不知道他是不是完全这么说的。但就像乔什·波特很在行。他有他的演示。他准备得很充分。然后你有，你知道，迈克尔大概处于中间位置。
Yeah. Because he does actually have a binder. He hands something out. Yeah. And then you have Craig who didn't prepare at all. Right. And Dan, we don't get to see. Oh, well, actually, he's sort of finishing his.
是的。因为他确实有一个活页夹。他分发了一些东西。是的。然后你有克雷格，他根本没准备。对。还有丹，我们没看到。哦，好吧，实际上，他正在完成他的。
And he goes, and that's how we're doing it, or whatever. I think Mike was saying it was important that they wanted to show that although Michael Scott does this crazy video, that he also did come prepared. He's not like Craig. He's not completely incompetent. Yes. Well, let's not completely incompetent. Yes. Well, let's talk about that video.
他说，这就是我们做事的方式，或者类似的话。我想迈克是说，重要的是他们想展示，尽管迈克尔·斯科特拍了这个疯狂的视频，但他确实也做了准备。他不像克雷格。他并非完全无能。是的。好吧，让我们谈谈那个视频。
When Michael starts his presentation, he presents Faces of Scranton, which is a video of the people at the Scranton branch set to With or Without You by U2. How could we afford that? We must have blown our whole budget on that song. With or without you? Yeah. By you too? Yeah. How could we afford that? We must have blown our whole budget on that song. And it's like not in slow motion, but it's not in regular motion. It's a little slowed down. It's a little slowed down, so everyone is like blinking real slow and waving to camera
当迈克尔开始他的演示时，他展示了“斯克兰顿的面孔”，这是一个关于斯克兰顿分公司员工的视频，配乐是U2的《With or Without You》。我们怎么负担得起那个？我们一定把全部预算都花在那首歌上了。《With or Without You》？是的。U2的？是的。我们怎么负担得起那个？我们一定把全部预算都花在那首歌上了。而且它不是慢动作，但也不是正常速度。它稍微放慢了一点，所以每个人眨眼都很慢，对着镜头挥手
real slow. Yeah, walking slowly, sitting slowly. We had a fan question from Rebecca Heaven. She said, did Steve actually film the footage from the business meeting presentation video? Did you get any intel when you were talking with Randall about how they made Faces of Scranton? Randall said that he filmed that specifically for this episode. Okay.
也很慢。是的，走得很慢，坐得很慢。我们有一个来自丽贝卡·海文的粉丝提问。她说，史蒂夫真的拍摄了商务会议演示视频中的镜头吗？当你和兰德尔谈论他们是如何制作“斯克兰顿的面孔”时，你得到什么内幕了吗？兰德尔说他是专门为这一集拍摄的。好的。
It wasn't pieced together from other footage. That was my question. That he actually filmed that. I noticed I'm wearing the wardrobe from Boys and Girls. Did you notice? I did not. Yeah, so I think we filmed it the week prior because I'm in my Boys and Girls wardrobe,
它不是从其他镜头拼凑出来的。那是我的问题。他真的拍摄了那个。我注意到我穿着《男孩与女孩》里的服装。你注意到了吗？我没有。是的，所以我认为我们是在前一周拍摄的，因为我穿着《男孩与女孩》里的服装，
which we filmed the episode before this one. And you're not spray tanned. I'm not tan. In faces of scram. I'm not tan and I'm in my pinkranton. I'm not tan, and I'm in my pink sweater with my low ponytail. Oh, OK. Yeah.
我们在这一集之前拍摄了那一集。而且你没有喷雾美黑。我不黑。在“斯克兰顿的面孔”里。我不黑，我穿着我的粉色毛衣，扎着低马尾。哦，好的。是的。
So that, I think we filmed it right before. I'm happy to hear that, because my memory was that those shots were scripted in the script, that there was a description of Faces of Scranton. Particularly, I remember getting those shots of him like over my shoulder with the like the dialogue was scripted and then there were suggestions of what the shots should be. Definitely. The whole scene where I have the brownies and I'm looking kind of sour at him.
所以，我想我们是在那之前拍的。听到这个我很高兴，因为我的记忆是那些镜头在剧本里写好了，有关于“斯克兰顿的面孔”的描述。特别是，我记得拍那些他从我肩膀上方拍的镜头，对话是写好的，然后有关于镜头应该是什么样子的建议。绝对是。我拿着布朗尼，对他露出那种酸溜溜表情的整个场景。
That was all like planned out. Phil Shea had the brownies, the whole thing. Yeah. So, so yeah, Randall shot that specifically for this and there were beats that he had to hit. Now, the great thing is you guys, if you love it, go to the DVD extras because there's extended footage. What you see is actually condensed. There's actually more footage of faces of Scranton. Maybe that's the version that Michael submits to the film festivals.
那都是计划好的。菲尔·谢准备了布朗尼，整个过程。是的。所以，是的，兰德尔是专门为这个拍摄的，他必须达到一些节奏。现在，最棒的是，你们如果喜欢它，去看看DVD花絮，因为有加长版镜头。你看到的实际上是压缩过的。实际上有更多关于“斯克兰顿的面孔”的镜头。也许那是迈克尔提交给电影节的版本。
Well, but he tells, so he's like, but you know what, maybe it's not appropriate. Maybe not, maybe he will, maybe he won't. Maybe he won't. He's not sure. The video doesn't go over well, they're stunned. Oh my God, Melora's reaction as Jan is just amazing. Melora, you crushed it, I loved it.
嗯，但他告诉，所以他就像是，但你知道吗，也许这不合适。也许不，也许他会，也许他不会。也许他不会。他不确定。视频效果不好，他们惊呆了。天哪，梅洛拉作为简的反应真是太棒了。梅洛拉，你演得太好了，我喜欢。
So David just asked for his sales numbers. He's like, can I just get your sales numbers? And I was really worried for a second. I was like, oh no. But no, Michael has those too. He hands out some little binders. He was prepared. He had binders all ready to go. That's Michael in a nutshell. He's trying to be outside the box. He's trying to tug on your heartstrings and make this is his whole thing. He wants the work to be more than box, he's trying to tug on your heartstrings and make this is his whole thing. He wants the work to be more than just a binder of numbers. He wants it to be about people.
所以大卫只是问了他的销售数字。他就像是，我能只看你的销售数字吗？我有一秒钟真的很担心。我就像是，哦不。但没有，迈克尔也有那些。他分发了一些小活页夹。他准备好了。他准备好了活页夹。这就是迈克尔的本质。他试图跳出框框思考。他试图触动你的心弦，让这成为他的全部。他希望工作不仅仅是一个数字活页夹。他希望它是关于人的。
The thing is, they are his family. You know, things move at a slower pace. The song is with or without you. It has nothing to do in the workplace. It's is it's like a like a love song. Yeah. And and just when he was like our spend a day in Phyllis's pants. What does he say? Spend a day in Phyllis's pants is not what he says. Well he says like see what it's like to walk a day in Oscar's shoes or sit in Phyllis's pants. I don't know what he says about Phyllis's pants. It's right as she's sitting down in slow motion. I just love it. I hope this gave you a little taste of what life is like here at Dunder Mifflin Scranton. What it's like to walk a mile in Oscar's shoes or try on Phyllis's pants.
问题是，他们是他的家人。你知道，事情进展得比较慢。那首歌是《With or Without You》。它和工作场所毫无关系。它就像是一首情歌。是的。就在他说“在菲利斯的裤子里过一天”的时候。他说的是什么？“在菲利斯的裤子里过一天”不是他说的。嗯，他说的是“看看在奥斯卡的鞋子里走一天是什么感觉，或者坐在菲利斯的裤子里”。我不知道他关于菲利斯的裤子说了什么。就在她慢动作坐下的时候。我太喜欢了。我希望这让你们尝到了在邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿生活是什么感觉。看看在奥斯卡的鞋子里走一英里，或者试穿菲利斯的裤子是什么感觉。
There it is. Or try on Phyllis's pants. Okay, okay. So he says, try on Phyllis's pants in slow-mo as she's sitting down. Yes. Faces of Scranton and then the very end, great Scott. Mike said was, Mike sure said that was an afterthought that he just sort of added that last minute and they made it, but it's so funny. It's so funny. So funny. All right. So now we're going to go back to the office again after that presentation and Oscar is going to get some flowers. Not flowers.
就是那个。或者试穿菲利斯的裤子。好的，好的。所以他说，在慢动作中试穿菲利斯的裤子，当她坐下的时候。是的。“斯克兰顿的面孔”，然后在最后，伟大的斯科特。迈克说，迈克·舒尔说那是一个事后想到的点子，他只是在最后一分钟加进去的，他们做到了，但这太好笑了。太好笑了。太好笑了。好吧。所以现在我们要在那次演示之后再次回到办公室，奥斯卡要收到一些花。不是花。
He got a plant. Well, yeah. Which I think is perfect. Perfect. And he reads the card. He says they're from his mom. And I loved his choice of putting the card in his pocket. Yeah.
他收到了一盆植物。嗯，是的。我觉得这很完美。完美。他读了卡片。他说那是他妈妈送的。我喜欢他把卡片放进兜里的选择。是的。
He puts it in his pocket. Puts it in his pocket. Meredith has passed out. There's nothing for Pam. There's nothing for Angela. Yeah. And Meredith is getting annoyed. Meredith is going to sleep this one out. Here's a fan catch.
他把它放进兜里。放进兜里。梅雷迪斯晕倒了。帕姆什么都没有。安吉拉什么都没有。是的。梅雷迪斯开始烦躁了。梅雷迪斯要睡过去。这是一个粉丝发现。
At 14 minutes, 45 seconds, Adam West, 84, says, there's a huge week calendar on the wall beside accounting that you can see from both accounting and from reception. It's always there. It's always there. It's a dry erase board calendar. Yes. He said it has always bothered him that they abbreviate Thursday as T-H-U-S, thus, instead of T-H-U-R. And he said quote, it breaks my mind.
在14分45秒，亚当·韦斯特，84岁，说，会计旁边的墙上有一个巨大的周历，你可以从会计和接待处看到。它总是在那儿。它总是在那儿。那是一个干擦板日历。是的。他说他一直很困扰，他们把星期四缩写为T-H-U-S，而不是T-H-U-R。他说引用，“这让我抓狂。”
Well, I need to go back and see that. 14 minutes, 45 seconds. I mean, I know, I do remember the handwriting was a bit sloppy. There is a chance that R looks like an S if it's in cursive. I'm gonna go and look at it. I'm gonna go check it.
嗯，我得回去看看。14分45秒。我是说，我知道，我确实记得字迹有点潦草。如果用草书写，R看起来像S是有可能的。我要去看看。我要去检查一下。
So you're thinking it's T-H-U-R? You know what, I'll tell you what, it's not written in cursive. The days of the week are taped out. Oh. In block letters. T-H-U-S thus. That would make me crazy too.
所以你认为它是T-H-U-R？你知道吗，我告诉你，它不是用草书写的。星期几是用胶带贴出来的。哦。用印刷体。T-H-U-S。那也会让我抓狂的。
Yeah, it's really bothering Adam. That's a crazy good catch. I'm gonna go check it out. And I think it's just always that way. I can't wait. I can't wait to go check it out. All right, so next, Jim's in the kitchen with Kelly. And he is giving her like, he is being a good friend, actually.
是的，这真的让亚当很困扰。那是一个非常好的发现。我要去检查一下。而且我想它一直都是那样。我等不及了。我等不及要去检查一下了。好吧，接下来，吉姆在厨房和凯利在一起。他正在给她，他实际上是一个好朋友。
He's being gentle. And he's like, you know what? He's just not into you. It would be great if he was, but he's not. So you just have to suck it up. Both Jim and Pam are saying to others, they're giving advice to others in this episode. Pam gives advice to Dwight, and she says something
他很温柔。他说，你知道吗？他就是不喜欢你。如果他喜欢你会很好，但他不喜欢。所以你只能忍受。吉姆和帕姆在这一集中都在对别人说，他们都在给别人建议。帕姆给德怀特建议，她说了一些
where it's just Pam projecting, where she says, you know, it's just, you want her to think that you thought of her. Yeah, it's not what you give her, it's that she knows you thought of her. Right, and that's desperately what Pam wants. She just wants to feel like Roy thinks of her, it's that she knows you thought of her. Right? And that's desperately what Pam wants. She just wants to feel like Roy thinks of her, ever. Ever thinks of her.
只是帕姆在投射，她说，你知道，只是，你想让她认为你想到她了。是的，不是你给了她什么，而是她知道你想到她了。对，而这正是帕姆迫切想要的。她只是想感觉罗伊想到她了，而是她知道你想到她了。对吧？而这正是帕姆迫切想要的。她只是想感觉罗伊想到她了，哪怕一次。哪怕一次想到她。
And then Jim is saying to Kelly, look, it'd be nice if he was into you, but he's not. You just got to let it go. And of course, Jim is talking about Pam. Yes. Yes. And Kelly doesn't hear any of it. Kelly does not get it. She's like, you know, he invites her to poker and she's like, can I invite Ryan?
然后吉姆对凯利说，看，如果他喜欢你会很好，但他不喜欢。你只能放手。当然，吉姆是在说帕姆。是的。是的。而凯利根本没听进去。凯利没明白。她就像是，你知道，他邀请她去打扑克，她就像是，我可以邀请瑞恩吗？
And the face John does when she says that is like, come on. Come on. Really? All right. So again, back to New York, we go back and forth between New York and Scranton a lot in this episode. This is when we find out that Craigers did not prepare anything for the meeting,
当她说那话时，约翰做的表情就像是，拜托。拜托。真的吗？好吧。所以再次回到纽约，我们在这一集中在纽约和斯克兰顿之间来回切换了很多次。这是我们发现克雷格在会议前什么都没准备的时候，
because he thought it was more of a meet and greet. Well, he's also just a slacker. He's a slacker. For sure. And he ignores direct orders. I think his performance is so delicious. And he kind of gets in trouble. Jan says, this does not bode well for your branch. And then he throws her under the bus.
因为他以为这更多是一个见面会。嗯，他也是个懒鬼。他是个懒鬼。肯定的。而且他无视直接命令。我觉得他的表现太精彩了。他有点惹麻烦了。简说，这对你的分公司来说不是好兆头。然后他把她推向了风口浪尖。
Yeah. He's like, what? I mean, I guess I'd get better treatment, you know, if we hooked up, like that's what he's inferring, right? Because she, you hooked up with Michael. He flat out says Michael made a stupid movie and didn't get in any trouble. Maybe I should have slept with you too. Oh yeah. Boom. Screech. This heads us into the Jan Michael scene. And Jan is just so defeated. She's like, Michael, it's like, I can't. My career's over.
是的。他就像是，什么？我是说，我想如果我们要好，我会得到更好的待遇，你知道，他是在暗示这个，对吧？因为她，你和迈克尔好过。他直截了当地说迈克尔拍了一部愚蠢的电影，却没惹任何麻烦。也许我也应该和你睡。哦，是的。砰。刺耳。这把我们带到了简和迈克尔的场景。简非常沮丧。她说，迈克尔，就像是，我不能。我的职业生涯结束了。
Yeah, I can't believe it. Like, you don't understand. For the new CFO to find out that I would have slept with an employee, she's like, I can't believe you. Why? Why are you you? And Michael just says, he's gonna fix it. He's gonna talk to David Wallace.
是的，我不敢相信。就像，你不明白。让新任首席财务官发现我会和员工睡觉，她就像是，我不敢相信你。为什么？为什么你是你？迈克尔只是说，他会解决的。他会和大卫·华莱士谈谈。
And you just see Michael loves Jan so much. He feels so bad. Like I think he finally gets it. He's like, wow. He feels bad. He feels bad, but he still makes a really lame joke. He's like, and don't call me Shirley. He can't resist kind of just being an idiot.
你就能看出迈克尔是多么爱简。他感到非常糟糕。就像我想他终于明白了。他就像是，哇。他感到糟糕。他感到糟糕，但他还是开了一个非常蹩脚的玩笑。他就像是，别叫我雪莉。他无法抗拒那种做一个白痴的感觉。
He can't resist it. Yeah. He's trying to make her feel better and then has to like put a joke in and look to camera. Oh, Michael. So I'm gonna jump ahead to the scene where Michael does go into David Wallace's office. And then we'll go back to Dunder Mifflin
他无法抗拒。是的。他试图让她感觉好点，然后不得不加一个笑话并看向镜头。哦，迈克尔。所以我要跳到迈克尔走进大卫·华莱士办公室的场景。然后我们会回到邓德·米夫林
and talk about what's happening there. But Michael does go into David Wallace's office and he says, it's not true. I didn't sleep with Jan. I just made a joke. This is all my fault. Yeah, it's a joke. It's all my fault. It was a bad joke.
谈谈那里发生了什么。但迈克尔确实走进了大卫·华莱士的办公室，他说，这不是真的。我没和简睡觉。我只是开了个玩笑。这都是我的错。是的，这是个玩笑。这都是我的错。那是个糟糕的玩笑。
I'm so sorry. And Jan kind of perks up like, oh yes, it's a joke. It's totally a joke. It didn't happen. And David Wallace kind of accepts this. He's like, okay. Michael promises it will never happen again. And all is forgiven. Like, they don't get in trouble. It's okay. But I want you to know that I noticed something on David Wallace's desk in this scene. What? At 19 minutes, 24 seconds, David Wallace has a world's best boss mug. Oh my god. But it's black with white cursive writing.
我很抱歉。简有点振作起来，就像，哦是的，这是个玩笑。这完全是个玩笑。没发生过。大卫·华莱士接受了这个说法。他就像是，好的。迈克尔保证再也不会发生这种事了。一切都被原谅了。就像，他们没惹麻烦。没关系。但我希望你知道，在这个场景中，我注意到大卫·华莱士的桌上有东西。什么？在19分24秒，大卫·华莱士有一个“世界最佳老板”杯子。天哪。但它是黑色的，上面有白色的草书。
Nice catch, lady! Yeah, yeah. If you freeze frame it. Oh, that's a really good catch. Yeah. Oh, that's a really good catch. Yeah. Oh, wow. And I have to imagine that that was a choice and that they, that's a very subtle Phil Shea thing. Yes.
好眼力，女士！是的，是的。如果你定格画面。哦，那真是个很好的发现。是的。哦，那真是个很好的发现。是的。哦，哇。我不得不想象那是一个选择，而且他们，那是菲尔·谢非常微妙的东西。是的。
Yeah. That's the kind of sense of humor that Phil Shea has, that he gave him a world's best boss mug on his desk. I love that. Isn't that great? All right. So back at the office, Angela finally gets her gift from Dwight. Yes, it is a key.
是的。那就是菲尔·谢的那种幽默感，他在他的桌上放了一个“世界最佳老板”杯子。我喜欢那个。那不是很棒吗？好吧。所以回到办公室，安吉拉终于从德怀特那里收到了她的礼物。是的，是一把钥匙。
Angela, your performance in the scene is so good. Oh. Your real is that you get this key, and you're like, what is this? Just a key? I feel like I could hear your whole interior monologue. What is this? This is a key.
安吉拉，你在这一幕中的表演太棒了。哦。你真实的感觉是你拿到了这把钥匙，你就像是，这是什么？只是一把钥匙？我觉得我能听到你整个内心的独白。这是什么？这是一把钥匙。
I don't even know what this. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Yeah. Like you're so delighted. It's so great.
我甚至不知道这是什么。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。是的。就像你太高兴了。太棒了。
I had a fan question. Jenny Zislin asks, was the key Dwight gave Angela for her to move in or just for her to have when she wants to stay there? What do you think? I think it's an all access pass. I don't think I move in. We're not ready for that.
我有一个粉丝提问。珍妮·齐斯林问，德怀特给安吉拉的钥匙是让她搬进去，还是只是为了让她想待在那儿时用？你觉得呢？我觉得这是一个全权通行证。我不认为我搬进去了。我们还没准备好。
Yeah. But it means I get to come and go now as I please. Yes. I had the same interpretation. Yes. That's what I think too. And she's thrilled by it. And in the bloopers, one of my favorite bloopers from this episode, they're on YouTube, there
是的。但这意味着我现在可以随心所欲地来去。是的。我有同样的解读。是的。我也这么认为。她对此感到非常激动。在花絮中，这一集中我最喜欢的花絮之一，它们在YouTube上，有
was the thought at first that Dwight would give her this gift with a card. Okay. Okay. So Dwight was going to write a card and he wanted Jim's help in writing a card for a girl. He doesn't say who it's for. And so he starts, Jim doesn't want to help him really. He gives him a hard time and Dwight's like annoyed.
最初的想法是德怀特会带着一张卡片送她这个礼物。好的。好的。所以德怀特要写一张卡片，他想让吉姆帮他给一个女孩写卡片。他没说那是给谁的。所以他开始，吉姆并不真的想帮他。他让他很难堪，德怀特很恼火。
So Dwight is sitting here trying to write this card and Jim is hearing all of it and they're in the bloopers and it is hilarious. But if you want to see John Krasinski break really hard, watch the bloopers on YouTube when Dwight writes, you are evil like a hobbit. This is the Valentine's card you might give Angela This is the Valentine's card you might give Angela and John loses it. So that's a fun blooper moment. Well next up, Roy comes in and Pam is done. She's very annoyed. And Roy is like, what's wrong? Are you upset?
所以德怀特坐在这儿试图写这张卡片，吉姆听到了这一切，他们在花絮里，这太搞笑了。但如果你想看约翰·卡拉辛斯基真的笑场，去YouTube上看花絮，当德怀特写道，你像霍比特人一样邪恶。这是你可能会给安吉拉的情人节卡片，这是你可能会给安吉拉的情人节卡片，约翰笑疯了。所以那是一个有趣的花絮时刻。好吧，接下来，罗伊进来了，帕姆受够了。她非常恼火。罗伊就像是，怎么了？你不高兴吗？
And she's like, yeah, I mean, I know I said don't spend a lot, but I thought I'd get something. But not only that, the person that fills in the blanks when Roy consistently fails is Jim. Yeah. And he didn't fill in the blanks. So she's filling it more than ever. It's magnified. She didn't get a cute little card from Jim this year. He gave her nothing this year. But Roy tells her, it's not over yet, baby. Yeah. Let's get you home and you're going to have the best sex of your life. Your reaction to that was so perfect. Oh my gosh. We had a fan question from Jonia Woods. What is the worst Valentine's gift you've ever received? What is the worst Valentine's gift you've ever received? Have you ever gotten anything worse than what Pam gets from Roy?
她说，是啊，我是说，我知道我说过别花太多钱，但我以为我会收到什么。不仅如此，当罗伊持续失败时，填补空白的人是吉姆。是的。而他没有填补空白。所以她比以往任何时候都更感到空虚。它被放大了。她今年没从吉姆那里收到可爱的卡片。他今年什么都没给她。但罗伊告诉她，还没结束呢，宝贝。是的。带你回家，你会拥有你一生中最棒的性生活。你对此的反应太完美了。天哪。我们有一个来自乔尼亚·伍兹的粉丝提问。你收过最糟糕的情人节礼物是什么？你收过最糟糕的情人节礼物是什么？你有没有收到过比帕姆从罗伊那里收到的更糟糕的东西？
The best sex of her life. Oh my gosh. I mean, I was dating a guy one time and he got me salsa. Really? Was it special? Was it from somewhere that you enjoyed salsa together? No. This wasn't a bad gift. Okay. It was just odd. It was just odd. It was homemade salsa.
她一生中最棒的性生活。天哪。我是说，我曾经和一个男人约会，他给了我莎莎酱。真的？那是特别的吗？那是来自你们一起享受莎莎酱的地方吗？不是。这不是一个糟糕的礼物。好的。这只是奇怪。这只是奇怪。那是自制的莎莎酱。
Did he make it? No. A coworker made it. I think the coworker gave it to him. And then he was like, oh, I got you salsa maybe. Do you like salsa? I like it salsa maybe. Do you like salsa? I like it, OK? I mean, it's like kind of getting like a condiment. Like here's some mayonnaise. Happy Valentine's, my friend makes their own mayonnaise.
是他做的吗？不是。一个同事做的。我想是同事给他的。然后他就像是，哦，我给你莎莎酱，也许。你喜欢莎莎酱吗？我喜欢，好的？我是说，这就像是收到某种调味品。就像这里有一些蛋黄酱。情人节快乐，我的朋友自己做蛋黄酱。
Listen, I tried it. It was good salsa. But it was kind of like, OK, well, I think I see the writing on the wall here. How much longer did you guys date? Not much longer. Really? Yeah, not much, just a few more months later.
听着，我试过了。那是很好的莎莎酱。但这就像是，好的，好吧，我想我看到了墙上的字。你们又约会了多久？没多久。真的？是的，没多久，只是几个月后。
Shocker. But you know, I am not, like I don't need a big gift. It's kind of like that thing, if you thought of me, great. Yeah. But it was just really random. And I really, really think his coworker made everyone salsa for Valentine's and he basically gave me.
震惊。但你知道，我不是，我不想要什么大礼物。这就像是那件事，如果你想到我了，很好。是的。但这真的很随机。而且我真的，真的认为他的同事给每个人都做了情人节莎莎酱，他基本上给了我。
He regifted. He regifted salsa. What about you? I can't think of a worst gift. I can't think of a best gift either. I think most of my Valentine's days have come and gone without much fanfare. I mean. I love flowers. I do. Flowers are nice. I'm sort of old fashioned that way. I love flowers. I do. Flowers are nice. Old fashioned that way. I love flowers. And you know what? My husband was like,
他转送了。他转送了莎莎酱。你呢？我想不出最糟糕的礼物。我也想不出最好的礼物。我想我的大多数情人节都平淡无奇地过去了。我是说。我喜欢花。我喜欢。花很好。我在这方面有点老派。我喜欢花。我喜欢。花很好。老派。我喜欢花。你知道吗？我丈夫就像是，
Ange, I am not a mind reader. I am not good at this. If you want something for Valentine's, you have to tell me because I am going to get it wrong. So I just said to him when we first got married, I was like, babe, just always get me flowers and I'll be happy. You can put to my wife from, to wife, one year it was to semicolon wife from semicolon husband, but it was roses. I'm happy you got me flowers. I just like to get a nice card with a little note on it. I think that's why, you know, I married a writer, write me something good and a card, and I'm happy. And that's what he does. To wife, to wife, from husband. I guess very different. That's why you need the flowers. I want the flowers guys. All right. So now, you know,
安吉，我不是读心者。我不擅长这个。如果你想要情人节礼物，你必须告诉我，因为我会弄错。所以我们刚结婚时我就对他说，宝贝，总是给我买花，我会很高兴的。你可以写给我的妻子，给妻子，一年是给分号妻子，从分号丈夫，但那是玫瑰。我很高兴你给我买了花。我只是喜欢收到一张带有小纸条的漂亮卡片。我想这就是为什么，你知道，我嫁给了一个作家，给我写点好的东西在卡片上，我就很高兴了。这就是他做的。给妻子，给妻子，从丈夫。我猜非常不同。这就是为什么你需要花。我想要花，伙计们。好吧。所以现在，你知道，
Pam just so desperately wants Jim to acknowledge her in any way today. And he doesn't know he just walks past kind of taps her desk says happy Valentine's Day and your little bye is the saddest thing at the end. So sad. Like bye. I'm gonna go home, get the best sex of my life. I can't wait. Happy Valentine's Day to me. Per Roy. Yeah, what is, what level of investment is that from Roy? I don't even want to think about it. And then Phyllis and the enormous bear. You know the writers just wanted to see her carry that bear. Oh my gosh. We got a lot of questions about where did that bear come from?
帕姆只是非常迫切地希望吉姆今天能以任何方式承认她。而他不知道，他只是走过去，拍了拍她的桌子，说了情人节快乐，而你那句小小的“再见”是最后最悲伤的事情。太悲伤了。就像再见。我要回家了，享受我一生中最棒的性生活。我等不及了。祝我情人节快乐。罗伊说的。是的，罗伊的投入程度是多少？我甚至不想去想它。然后菲利斯和巨大的熊。你知道编剧只是想看她抱着那只熊。天哪。我们收到了很多关于那只熊从哪儿来的问题？
And I'm sorry, I couldn't get you an answer, but where did that bear come from? I don't know. That's insane. That's a Phil Shea classic. Now in the deleted scenes, there's one that is hilarious. Uh-huh. Michael actually gives all the ladies a Valentine.
我很抱歉，我没能给你答案，但那只熊从哪儿来的？我不知道。那太疯狂了。那是菲尔·谢的经典之作。现在在删减片段里，有一个非常搞笑的。嗯哼。迈克尔确实给了所有女士一个情人节礼物。
Yes. So in Pam's talking head at the beginning, she talks about how people at the office hand things out, and there's actually a bunch of deleted scenes of people handing things out, including Michael, who hands out a bunch of plastic roses. Plastic roses that have thorns, and then his card says, me so thorny. Yeah. Oh. That's what we all want. And then one other deleted scene before we wrap up this episode, you guys, is that when Michael
是的。所以在帕姆开头的谈话中，她谈到了办公室里的人分发东西，实际上有一堆人分发东西的删减片段，包括迈克尔，他分发了一堆塑料玫瑰。带有刺的塑料玫瑰，然后他的卡片上写着，我太带刺了。是的。哦。那正是我们都想要的。然后在我们结束这一集之前，还有一个删减片段，伙计们，就是当迈克尔
is walking on the streets of New York, he walks past Devin. Oh, yes. And Devin recognizes him and is ticked off and kind of chases after him. Yes, because Devon was now in real life, living in New York and doing theater. So they called him up when they were gonna be in New York to have this additional cameo. And unfortunately, it did not make the cut.
走在纽约街头时，他走过了德文。哦，是的。德文认出了他，很生气，有点追着他跑。是的，因为德文现在在现实生活中住在纽约，从事戏剧工作。所以当他们要在纽约时，他们打电话给他，让他进行这次额外的客串。但不幸的是，它没能入选。
It's a very funny deleted scene though. So you guys have to go check it out. And Michael has a talking head about it that's also deleted. Well, the very end of this episode, Jan catches Michael as he's getting in the elevator at corporate. And she just says, Thank you, Michael. Thank you so much. And he's like, Yeah, okay. And once again, he's oddly impressed her. Yes. And he's very calm and he's clearly like, I get it. It's over. It's over and I'm never ever gonna go there again.
不过这是一个非常有趣的删减片段。所以你们一定要去看看。迈克尔还有一个关于它的谈话，也是删减的。好吧，这一集的最后，简在公司电梯里抓住了迈克尔。她只是说，谢谢你，迈克尔。非常感谢。他就像是，是的，好的。再一次，他奇怪地打动了她。是的。他非常冷静，他显然就像是，我明白了。结束了。结束了，我再也不会去那儿了。
And then she kisses him. Jan! Jan. Jan! You are torturing this man. What are you doing? Jan, you're self-destructive. Oh my gosh. And you even see her look around.
然后她吻了他。简！简。简！你在折磨这个男人。你在做什么？简，你是自我毁灭的。天哪。你甚至看到她环顾四周。
She looks over her shoulder to see if they're alone. And then she kisses him, but she forgot to look over the other shoulder. But Michael knew immediately. He looked right at camera and was like, uh, uh. And then she looks at camera and she's like, oh, forget about it. Forget about it. Oh boy. And then that is how the episode ends.
她回头看，看他们是否单独在一起。然后她吻了他，但她忘了看另一边。但迈克尔立刻就知道了。他直接看向镜头，就像是，呃，呃。然后她看向镜头，就像是，哦，忘掉它吧。忘掉它吧。哦，男孩。然后这就是这一集结束的方式。
That is how the episode ends. It's such a good one. And I have kind of a fun journal entry that I wrote. During this week, I wrote, John and I have a new goofy walk we do when we pretend to be kid sister and big brother. Well, you have to explain kid sister, big brother, because we've never even talked about that. Guys.
这就是这一集结束的方式。这真是太棒了。我有一种有趣的日记条目，我写过。这一周，我写道，约翰和我有一个新的傻乎乎的走路方式，当我们假装是小妹妹和大哥哥时。嗯，你得解释一下小妹妹和大哥哥，因为我们从来没谈过那个。伙计们。
So John and I, you guys, we would have some downtime between scenes and we would just kind of hang out and sometimes he'd get a little punchy as the day would go. And John's, when I stand next to John, he's so much taller than me. We both sort of remembered this childhood doll that you could buy that was called kid sister that stands about three feet tall and you could hold her hand and kind of make her walk.
所以约翰和我，伙计们，我们在场景之间会有一些空闲时间，我们只是闲逛，有时随着一天的过去，他会变得有点冲动。约翰的，当我站在约翰旁边时，他比我高得多。我们俩都记得这个你可以买到的童年玩偶，叫小妹妹，大约三英尺高，你可以牵着她的手，让她走路。
And John and I made up this whole thing where he would hold my hand and I'd pretend to be the kid sister doll. And he'd go, kid sister, and I'd go big brother. Yes. And we made up this whole goofy walk and everything. So this is, this is what was happening behind the scenes. Yes.
约翰和我编造了整个事情，他会牵着我的手，我假装是小妹妹玩偶。他会说，小妹妹，我会说大哥哥。是的。我们编造了整个傻乎乎的走路方式等等。所以这就是，这就是幕后发生的事情。是的。
While we were all, we loved when you guys did kid sister, big brother. That was very entertaining for our downtime. You guys were a good team. So you came up with a new walk. I guess a new goofy walk. We had a new bit to do. All right, you guys, that was the Valentine's episode.
当我们都在的时候，我们喜欢你们做小妹妹和大哥哥。这对我们的空闲时间来说非常有趣。你们是一个很好的团队。所以你们想出了一个新的走路方式。我猜是一个新的傻乎乎的走路方式。我们有一个新的片段要做。好吧，伙计们，那是情人节那一集。
Yes, and next up is Dwight's speech. Another really good one. Really good, and we'd like to thank Andy Buckley so much for stopping by. Yes, and thank you Randall Einhorn for all of your insider tidbits. Yes, and for more stuff, guys, don't forget to check out the DVD commentary
是的，接下来是德怀特的演讲。又一个非常好的。真的很好，我们要非常感谢安迪·巴克利过来。是的，感谢兰德尔·艾恩霍恩提供的所有内幕消息。是的，还有更多东西，伙计们，别忘了去看看DVD评论
and the bloopers. There's good stuff there. And thank you so much for sending in your questions. Yeah, happy Valentine's Day, everyone. Happy Valentine's Day. Enjoy your salsa. Angela, wait, can you please, I have a new merchandise idea for Office Ladies.
和花絮。那里有好东西。非常感谢你们寄来问题。是的，祝大家情人节快乐。情人节快乐。享受你们的莎莎酱。安吉拉，等等，你能请，我有一个新的办公室女士周边点子。
It's Valentine's Day salsa. Oh no, that guy's gonna crawl all the woodworks and be like, I think I'm gonna cut that salsa. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
那是情人节莎莎酱。哦不，那个家伙会从木制品里爬出来，就像是，我想我要切掉那个莎莎酱。感谢收听办公室女士的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。办公室女士是Odyssey的呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。